So Leute, ich bin mal wieder da, vor 10 Stunden war ich schon mal da.
Ich habe nichts zu tun heute Abend, großartig, habe ich mir gedacht, komm weißt du was, wir
schwätzen ein bisschen und basteln ein bisschen weiter an unseres Welts Übungsanwendung.
Hat ja an Weihnachten sonst nichts besseres zu tun.
Oh, ich merke gerade, ich muss mich noch einloggen, in der Cloud, ohne dass ihr es seht, oder
aber, ich mache das einfach Offscreen, dann könnt ihr es nicht sehen, eher, wahrscheinlich
mache ich das einfach Offscreen, heute ist ja nicht Sponsort.
Cookies erlauben, Login, Cloud, muss nämlich noch ein Nordbalancer anlegen.
So, OTP eingeben, OTP eingeben, wo ist meine Authenticator App, ich finde das Ding immer
nicht, Authenticator App, Massive Big Brain Pin, so, Verify, nice, ok, ich log mich doch
mal Onstream ein, ich log mich doch mal Onstream ein, dass ihr zugucken könnt, wenn ich den
Nordbalancer anlege, ich glaube, das ist ganz interessant, die Geschichte, aber da muss
ich euch zumindest für den Username und Zeug erstmal kurz ausmachen, Incognito, rein theoretisch
frage ich, wie viele Subs muss ich giften, damit du einen Stream lang die Qt.VM benutzt,
gar keinen, das Problem ist, das ist ein uraltes Ubuntu, das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn,
das zu verwenden, das kann man auch für kaum was richtig verwenden, ihr müsst jetzt mal
kurz die Augen zumachen, keiner gucken, ok, keiner gucken, wenn ich mich einlogge.
Keiner spicken, Uber, keiner abgucken hier, so, One Time Token eingeben, zack, Stream,
ok, da sind wir, alles klar, ich mach euch wieder an, ich mach euch wieder an, so, da
sind wir, damit wir nämlich, ich mach halt keinen super krassen Tetzner sehr laut oder
sowas, aber damit wir, damit wir die App, damit ihr die App angucken könnt, brauchen
wir ja wieder ein Notbalancer, dass das funktioniert, oh, ich muss die DNS-Geschichte auch noch
umleiten, ja gut, du hattest auch japanisch ein bisschen, oh wir haben 16 an Zuschauer,
top, Max wie war die Weihnachtsfeier auf der Arbeit, ich war nicht da, was soll ich da,
geht doch gar nicht hin, ich glaube es war dieses Jahr auch gar keine, so, also ihr wisst
ja, wir haben hier eine super nice Domain, nämlich todo.caqw.services und das geht gerade
nicht, weil ich gestern den Notbalancer gelöscht habe, weil ich keinen Bock habe 5€ im Monat
zu bezahlen für eine Kiste, die ich nicht brauche, deswegen legen wir ein Notbalancer
an, weil wir beliebig viele App-Server dahinter haben können, so, was muss man, was muss man
achten, wenn man Notbalancer anlegt, auch an Weihnachten, da muss ich überlegen, wo
kriegt man das Zertifikat her, wo stellt man das Zertifikat denn jetzt nochmal ein, also
wir wollen HTTPS, Port 3000, so viel weiß ich noch, hier Zertifikat todo.caqw.services
add Zertifikat, Nürnberg, Loadbalancer, Kicks, todo, LB, so, wenn ich alles richtig
gemacht habe, sollte das jetzt funktionieren, ja, ich muss DNS kurz umstellen, Leute, dürft
ihr wieder nicht gucken, das hätte ich alles vorm Stream machen sollen, aber kann man
jetzt nicht ändern, DNS umstellen, caqw.services, save, ok, alles klar, wir sind wieder am Start,
VM starten, Display Capture starten, nice, ok, jetzt kann es, jetzt kann es aber losgehen,
ich zeige euch mal, wo wir stehen geblieben sind das letzte Mal, ich mache mal ein bisschen
anderes gedudeln, ich zeige euch mal, wo wir stehen geblieben sind bei der Test App,
dass ihr so ungefähr, ja wisst, was wir gemacht haben, oh Leute, ich habe jetzt die Auswahl
zwischen, ich könnte jetzt noch mal schnell einen, Zack, wie heißt der Kram, Pralinen
mit 41% Nugatrüffelfüllung futtern, ist aber keine gute Idee, dass ich das auf dem Schreibtisch
stehen habe, Leute, alternativ kann ich auch gegen, für den Hals, kann ich eine Runde
Ricola Weizer Kräuterzucker futtern, das mit Zucker meinen die aber ernst, oder alternativ
was wahrscheinlich für Pepofet auch die bessere Variante ist, eine runde Halspompon zuckerfrei
vom Lidl, glaube ich mache ich mal das, ist das ein Evoli, das ist wie ein Evoli, wo ist
das Evoli eigentlich, wir hatten mal einen Mod, der hieß das Evoli, den habe ich schon
lange nicht mehr gesehen, wer hat es erfunden, erfunden, genau, ja, nice, ich hoffe bei dir
gab es auch ordentlich Zeug, die App ist production ready, ja, ich zeige euch die App gleich mal,
das ist ein Evoli, sieht aus wie ein Evoli, ne, chemistry pokemon zeug nicht aus, aber
das sieht aus wie ein Evoli, so, der Load Balancer ist da, dann Ansible, ja, ich habe
das Ding ins Rebo gepusht vorhin, so, wir bauen mal kurz den Server auf, dass ihr euch den
aktuellen Stand angucken könnt, ich hoffe das funktioniert jetzt alles so, also wenn
das jetzt ordentlich durchläuft haben wir gleich einen App Server mit Debian 11, triple
core CPU und dann läuft ein Ansible Playbook und konfiguriert uns den Server, ok, schauen
wir mal ob das was ich da gebastelt habe, funktioniert, ah, ich habe das wichtigste
vergessen, ich muss den Load Balancer einstellen, Targets, Label, to do, so, das nimmt der Load
Balancer das nicht auf, aber sowas von production ready, oh Max hast du ne Empfehlung was man
für einen Host nehmen kann, für React Apps und Node.js Projekte ja und nein, kommt drauf
an, ob die rein kleinzeitig sind oder ob du ne Backend brauchst, also so wie ich dich
verstehe brauchst du ja noch ne Backend, also du hast ja Node.js Backends und React Frontend,
was hältst du von, also die klassische Variante ist natürlich, nimm dir ne VM bei Hetzner,
kannst du dir mal 20€ Startgutschein sichern, da musst du dich halt selbst drum kümmern,
dann hast du noch für das reine Hosting von der App hast du da noch so Sachen wie Netlify
zum Beispiel, wobei ich keine Ahnung habe wie es mit Netlify und Node.js Backends aussieht,
Netlify ist ja eigentlich nur zum Hosten der Frontend Geschichten, hat jemand schon mal
Netlify in Verbindung mit Node.js gemacht, da brauchst du wahrscheinlich trotzdem noch
irgendwo ne VM, wo du dein Node Zeug laufen lassen kannst oder du machst eh nen Container
und schiebst nach Azure oder Google Cloud oder so, ich hab Netlify noch nie gemacht, wobei
Netlify hat bestimmt auch die Möglichkeit Container laufen zu lassen oder?
Scheint geht das, oder scheint zu funktionieren, wobei du da wahrscheinlich mehr bezahlen wirst
als bei nem normalen VM, jaja also da darf man sich nicht davon chibaten lassen, das
klingt immer so super cool diese Sachen mit ja bezahle genauso viel nur wie du brauchst,
aber über einen wirklich minimalen Basic Wert hinausgehend bist du in der Regel mit
einer stinknormalen VM, zum Beispiel bei Henshner billiger als wenn du dir irgendwelche Azure
Functions Dinge oder so machst, aber klar du musst dich halt auch selbst darum kümmern.
So guck mal hier, Ansible ist durchgelaufen, jetzt sollten wir ein To-Do, To-Do keqw.service,
haben, Leute es funktioniert, nein funktioniert nicht, warum gehts nicht, was ist kaputt,
geht die App bei euch, To-Do Server Healthy, Leute geht die App bei euch, warum geht die
App nicht, klappt, das ist ein DNS Problem, ach ne jetzt funktionierts, alter das ist ja
mal krass, huge, lahm, was ist denn jetzt los, warum ist das so langsam, das ist mal
mega lahm, ok Leute mal kurz, FireFox, FireFox aus, To-Do, alter was ist denn da los, machen
wir einen Curl, was ist denn das, hat Henshner gerade irgendwelche Schwierigkeiten oder liegt
es an mir, machen wir mal kurz hier den auf und gucken mal was passiert, ja Port 3000,
das ist der Loadbalancer der langsam ist, oder ist mein DNS noch nicht geupdatet, Sekunde,
mein DNS ist bestimmt noch nicht upgedatet, guck mal, 16, was hat der Loadbalancer, mein
DNS ist noch nicht refreshed, mein DNS hat es noch nicht gecheckt, dass die IP anders
ist, guckt, ja, das ist, es müsste eigentlich 144 hinten haben, fragen wir mal bei Google
an, ach die haben noch gar nicht aktualisiert, bei Cloudflare hat es schon aktualisiert,
guckt, also wenn ihr Cloudflare DNS macht gehts über Google DNS, ah, der Google DNS
ist gerade noch ein bisschen, der weiß noch nicht genau, welches das jetzt ist, aber Google
DNS ist auch immer so eine Sache, das ist ja Anycast, du kommst nicht immer beim gleichen
Google DNS raus und manche haben schon aktualisiert und manche nicht, natürlich doof, ja, dann
müssen wir kurz warten, bis das aktualisiert hat, das dauert ja meist nur 2, 3 Minuten,
ja das ist, wie lernt man nochmal seinen Cache, clear, wobei, wahrscheinlich brauch ich das
auch gar nicht, der macht das ja automatisch neu, also zumindest der Browser fragt ja nochmal
an, ja also bei mir ist der Google DNS, Einweise noch nicht aktuell, guckt, aha, jetzt schon,
jetzt hat er es gecheckt, jetzt hat er es gecheckt, alles klar, ok wunderbar, so jetzt
könnt ihr euch das ganze angucken, hat man Windows schon kapiert, alter was ist mit meinem,
was ist mit meinem DNS Zeug los, der hat es noch gecached, muss ich mich jetzt ernsthaft
bei meinem Router einloggen und DNS clearen oder was, alter Lan, was ist hier los, DNS,
cache, ja, tu du, da ist es noch, der cache in meinem Router ist, jebaitet mich und der
läuft in 5 Minuten 48 ab, ich sag jetzt flash cache, so weg damit, cache geflasht und jetzt
sollte es eigentlich funktionieren, aha, jetzt funktioniert es auch, gut, jetzt sollte es
hier auch tun, alles klar, ok, also hier sind wir stehen geblieben, nee ich muss noch bei
meinem Router den DNS clearen, bisschen laut die Musik, aber so, ja das wird besser, also
ich sag euch mal wo wir stehen geblieben sind, das ist keine App, ich sag es gleich dazu,
das ist keine App wo ich irgendwie darauf abziele, dass da super viele Leute verwenden,
das ist rein, dass ich ein bisschen üben kann, wie das funktioniert, also was wir schon gemacht
haben das letzte Mal, das ganze ist übrigens in soweit responsive, dass es sich halbwegs
skalieren lässt und auf dem Handy den kleineren Button klickt, also guckt, der Button wird
ab einer gewissen Stelle größer, dass man auf dem Handy nicht irgendwie die halbe Seite
voll hat, Herzlichen Dankeschön für den Sub, so das ist eine simple To Do App, die im Prinzip
außer To Do's anlegen auch nichts großartiges kann, also To Do App, man kann To Do's anlegen
und man kann To Do's closen und die geklosen To Do's sortieren sich unten ein und oben
hat man, kennst du schon bessere C++ Alternative, Otto++, ja das sieht sehr, so aus als will
man das unbedingt lernen ja, vor allem bei dieser Webseite, guck mal hier, was auch immer
mir da grad der Chat geschickt hat, Otto++, Struktur trifft Tabelle, das sieht schon kommt,
das ist doch fake oder, es ist doch fake, wo ist das Impressum, deutsche Seite und kein
Impressum, direkt Anzeige raus, kein Impressum, direkt Anzeige Video, warum nennt man seine
Programmiersprache Otto++, who is, who is, genau, who is, ja, tatsächlich, ne, ja gut
man weiß ja nimmer, also kein Schimmer, was das, was das sein soll, aber hier kann man
Otto++ im, im, ai ai ai, ok, was auch immer, wir bleiben lieber bei uns, bei unserer To
do App, Rost, Rost auf Deutsch, oh es ist ein richtiger Paint-Champ, wenn gerade die Franzosen
immer anfangen ihre Variablen auf Französisch zu nennen, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben,
ich zeige euch übrigens mal ein richtig cooles ZSH Feature, guck mal, wenn man in dieses,
in dieses Verzeichnis hier oben rein will, ich mein, ihr kennt ja die Geschichte, dass
man sowas machen kann wie Repos, Tab, Keks, Tab, Ansible, Tab, das geht, aber man kann
auch sagen, Repo, Repo, Keks, Ansible und dann Tab drücken, ok, es ist nicht eindeutig
gewesen, aber jetzt ist eindeutig, ja, also man kann Repo, Keks, Ansible machen, Keks
ist auch doppelblick, aber ihr wisst was ich meine, er checkt es automatisch, Repo, Keks,
Ansible, zack, das ist sehr praktisch, ein sehr nice Feature, so das wars, mehr kann
diese super advanced High IQ To Do App nicht, achso ja doch, man kann To Do's noch löschen,
das funktioniert auch noch und dann ist der Progress hier oben, so und wenn man fertig
ist, dann ist der Progress bei 100% und man beachte, dass es sogar animiert wird, diese
Progress-Balten, seht ihr das, der Progress-Balten ist animated, weil, weil, huge, Animierung,
die Suche, ach Suche, das ist eine gute Idee, Suche können wir auch noch machen, ja, gute
Idee, Suche machen wir auch noch, so ich mache mal kurz hier auf, Repos, Keks, To Do, so
machen wir mal kurz auf, gucken wir uns den Sourcecode an, für alle die nicht dabei waren,
es ist wirklich ziemlich eklig gemacht, weil ich habe alles in einer Datei geschrieben,
das ist aber nicht viel, 140 Zeilen und 140 Zeilen, das ist alles JavaScript und HTML
und Styling, also da ist eigentlich gar nichts großartig kompliziertes dabei, ja die Daten
werden auch, das habe ich ganz vergessen, wenn ihr jetzt was hinzufügt und neu ladet,
dann behältst du das, also die Daten sind Local Storage gespeichert, ja, richtig, genau,
also wir machen, genau, wir machen Komponenten auslagern, aber das mit der Suche finde ich
ist schon mal eine gute Idee, Suche, Suche sollten wir auf jeden Fall noch machen, ich
habe mir überlegt, wir machen folgendes, also es gibt so ein paar, machen wir mal hier
so, machen wir mal ne To Do oder so, To Do ist für die To Do App, beste, Features, also
was wir einbauen können, ich suche, dann das sag mal mal, wie nennen wir das mal, ordentlich
machen, hübsch machen, auslagern in Komponenten mit Slots und Events, dass es ein bisschen
übersichtlicher wird, weil, ne das soll nicht da rein, das soll vielleicht da hin, Features.md.
So, wie gesagt die To Do App ist nicht dafür gedacht zu großartig zu benutzen, das ist
zum üben gedacht und ich will garantiert keine To Do App, die in meinem Local Storage ist
für repoweite Features, ja Gruppen, ich hab gedacht Gruppen, man könnte das Bücher oder
so nennen, dann könnte man hier oben so ne Leiste hin machen, buchen mit nem Name dran,
so nach dem Motto, verschiedene Notizbücher, Gruppen könnte man machen und ich hab mir
gedacht, wisst ihr was wir auch machen können, sharen, aber anders als ihr denkt, weil wir
haben ja kein Backend, aber was man machen könnte ist folgendes, man macht hier nen
share Button und dieser share Button, der generiert einfach nen Link zu diesem Service mit der
kompletten Base64 oder Gehzipten oder was auch immer, Dings in der Url und dann kann
man die copypasten und jemand anderes kann sich die rüber kopieren und dann kannst du
quasi die ganze To Do Liste sharen als Snapshot, natürlich editieren sich die nicht parallel
sondern einmalig, einmalig sind sie gleich und dann unterschiedlich, bringt das was
wenn man die To Do's, Chasen, Chasen Stringified, Gehzipt und dann Base64 encoded, ist das dann
kleiner anstatt, ja gut wahrscheinlich, floated, genau, im Prinzip genau, du schickst einem
den Link mit, du schickst einem den Link mit Base64 hinten dran und dann macht er daraus
wieder die richtigen To Do's, die Dotfiles sind ein bisschen outdated aber nicht so viel,
also das ist Manjaro mit I3, by the way Archlinux, Archlinux by the way, muss ich vielleicht
nochmal erwähnen, ich hab gehört, dass memen die Leute immer gern, dass man Archlinux verwendet
und dann kommen die Leute wieder, Max Manjaro ist kein Archlinux, das hab ich doch egal,
das ist alles archbasiert, aber nein, nein, nein, nein, Manjaro ist kein Archlinux, also
ich benutze übrigens Archlinux, was man übrigens by the way Archlinux und nicht Archlinux
ausspricht und die richtige Hackermann Umgebung habe ich auch direkt am Start, also wenn mal
einer, wenn der Chef vorbeikommt und es soll so aussehen als arbeitet, dann war es einfach
Hollywood starten.
Wie bist du drauf gekommen Manjaro zu verwenden?
Das ist eine gute Frage, ich glaube weil mir Ubuntu auf dem Desktop und diese ganzen Derivate
so auf den Sack gegangen sind und ich irgendwas mit aktueller Software haben wollte, aber
ich keinen Bock hatte auf normale Archlinux installieren und Installationen und da hab
ich gesagt, Manjaro ist so eigentlich relativ easy zu installieren, hast aber die kompletten
User Repos und alles was man so braucht, ich glaube das war mein Gedankengang dahinter.
Leute ich hatte gerade eine richtige High IQ Idee, wir probieren jetzt mal kurz aus ob
das funktioniert, ne wir machen erstmal kurz, wir machen erstmal die To Do's weiter und
vorher Open, starten wir das ganze mal lokal, damit wir das ausprobieren können.
Test 0B, so, also dann hab ich überlegt, wir können das sharen, gezip, base64 an url
oder irgendwie sowas, dass man sich To Do Listen sharen kann, wie gesagt es ist im Prinzip
alles nur zum üben, es ist nicht dafür gedacht, dass es am Ende wirklich verwendet wird, To
Do Apps gibt es in tausend Varianten und das ist überhaupt nichts neues und da gibt es
sicherlich auch deutlich featurekomplettere und bessere als das was ich hier zusammen
bastle, das ist einfach nur, dass ich bisschen Svelte üben kann, hab ich noch nie was mit
gemacht, ich hab da vor zwei Tagen mir das das erste Mal angeguckt und ich muss sagen,
bis jetzt finde ich es wirklich nice, aber ich denke wenn wir ein bisschen kompliziertere
Sachen machen, werde ich auch relativ schnell merken, ob es weiterhin nice bleibt oder ob
noch einige Sachen fehlen, mal gucken, mal gucken wie das ist, also man könnte das sharen
als link, also quasi To Do Liste sharen als link, könnte man noch machen, dann könnte
man delete all button oder sowas machen in der richtung, danach machen wir keine native
app, danach machen wir vielleicht eine pw art raus, kommt der dann, kommt der eh nicht
raus, shortcuts, shortcuts, also zum beispiel, keine Ahnung, alt plus enter gleich completed
für new und dann, könnte man zum beispiel machen, man könnte vielleicht noch prioritäten
an to dos machen oder so, und man könnte den Papierkorb machen, so das ist alles was
mir so einfällt, wenn ihr noch fife hat export als file, ja das vielleicht auch nicht so,
backup, das ist alles was mir so einfällt, was auch glaube ich relativ übersichtlich
ist, was man machen kann, übrigens leute ich muss was sagen, ich hatte die mega idee
gerade, guck mal, ich hab nämlich heute morgen im bett auf dem smartphone ein tailwind css
tutorial angeguckt und da hat er gezeigt, dass tailwind animationen standardmäßig mit
drinne hat und ich hab mir gedacht, wir könnten jetzt folgendes machen, guck mal, hier ist
doch der mülleimer und der mülleimer, der wird ja, wenn man hovert, wird der so pink
und da hab ich mir gedacht, was wir machen könnten ist, also guck das hier ist der knopf
für den mülleimer und magenta, aber es heißt offiziell pink, magenta ist ja rechtlich
copyrighted von der telekom, ich hab mir gedacht, wir könnten sowas hier machen, guck mal,
animate, spin und dann haben wir einen kogas mülleimer, der übrigens immer noch pink
wird, ne das hab ich mir nicht gedacht, jetzt mal ernsthaft, was ich mir gedacht hab, ist
folgendes, was wir machen könnten, guck mal, wir können sagen transition, stop transition
muss man angeben, transition, guck mal, jetzt transition die farbe schon ein bisschen,
seht ihr, vorher war es direkt, jetzt merkt ihr es, jetzt hat die farbe eine kleine verzügung
und aber ich hab mir gedacht, wir können jetzt sagen hover, hover und dann animate, bounce
oder sowas vielleicht, aber guck mal, jetzt hüpft er, jetzt haben wir einen hüpfenden
bounce, was haben wir sonst noch zur auswahl, pulse, ne, wie wärs mit scale, scale, irgendwie
125% oder so, ey das ist schick, das find ich net schlecht, guck mal hier und auch richtig
schön animiert, das find ich cool, da kann man nicht so vorbei tippen, das ist nicht
schick, jetzt haben wir einen animierten transition, transitierenden mülleimer, der pink wird
und scaled auf 150% und jetzt muss er natürlich noch ganz wichtig hover, animate, spin, das
ist ganz essentiell, oh, der spinnt ja überhaupt nicht, warum spinnt der jetzt nicht, ich mein,
das ist auch ganz cool, aber warum spinnt der jetzt nicht, soll der nicht spinnen, jetzt
pulst er nur, kann es sein, dass der nicht spinnt, weil spinnen irgendwie selbst auch
scale verwendet oder so, anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären, weil da spinnt er, guckt
und jetzt pulsiert er nur, hä, ok was auch immer, ich glaub wir lassen das sonst, sonst
haben wir es komplett kaputt, ich glaub es ist jetzt schon broken genug, ich glaub jetzt
ist es komplett genug, schon komplett kaputt, aber so, irgendwie bin ich grad auf die Idee
gekommen, Leute ich hab noch eine Idee was wir machen können, wie wärs denn, oh big
brain time, mal gucken wie wir das hinkriegen, eigentlich ist das nichts von dem was ich
hier reingeschrieben hab in features, aber fällt mir grad so ein, wie wärs denn, wenn
das Text fällt, wenn man draufklickt, größer wird, also es kann ja sein, dass man beispielsweise
mehrere Zeilen to do's haben will, sag mal bis zu 5 Zeilen oder so und wenn man das fokussiert,
dann fährt das aus, boah das muss ich jetzt ausbilden ob das funktioniert, also, Unterpunkte
wären besser, ne Unterpunkte sind nicht besser, weil Unterpunkte, wenn du Unterpunkte anlegst,
das müsstest du irgendwie in der Datenstruktur abbilden, ja, was weiß ich, vielleicht brauchen
wir ein bisschen längeres to do, was weiß ich, vielleicht braucht man ein to do, erst
Auto waschen, dann N64 auf Ebay kaufen und dann, und jetzt reichen die Zeilen nicht
mehr, so, dann 0w gachi roll aktivieren, siehste, das ist kacke, jetzt krollt das, krollt das
nicht richtig, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, da bin ich gespannt, also wir machen
mal, gibt es multi, multiline, ne, wie macht man den Input jetzt größer, track and drop
sorting, ne, track and drop ist bisschen, also ich schreibs mal auf, aber das ist wirklich
hier advanced, track and drop, das ist wirklich advanced dann schon, text area ist das besser
als Input, was ist der Unterschied zwischen text area und Input, man weiß es, aha, ah,
verstehe, ok, so, das wollen wir aber nicht, wir wollen standardmäßig haben, das war jetzt
rose, glaube ich, bei text area, ne, rose 1, ne, ich glaub das müssen wir mit CSS machen,
sections bzw überschriften für die to do's, wir könnten machen, dass die erste zeile
fett gerendert wird oder sowas vielleicht, also, ok, also wir wollen H8 oder so, was
ist das, H9 ist eine Zeile, ok, Focus, passt mal auf, vielleicht geht das ganz einfach,
vielleicht geht das ganz einfach, guck mal, Focus und jetzt sagen wir einfach 40, boah,
das klappt aus, huge und das jetzt noch animiert, Leute, und das jetzt noch animiert, dass es
smooth ausfährt, wie hast du gestern mpv und ascii die buchstaben size verändert, also
als erstes mal hab ich mpv kaga installiert, weil man für ascii rennen an mpv kaga braucht
und dann hab ich das terminal ganz klein gemacht, die schriftart und hab's noch mal gestartet
und dann geht das, aber guck mal, jetzt fährt es schon aus, richtig pogge, wie kriegen wir
das jetzt animiert, reicht das, wenn ich da einfach hinschreibe, transition, ne, gibt
es sowas wie transition height, transition height oder sowas, ne, ok, google fragen, google
weiß das, tailwind transition height, tailwind transition inside, was auch immer, transition
height duration, is in is out, extension method, die extension method ist doch eklig, ist das
nicht standardmäßig dabei, seriously, oh guck mal, was ist denn das, from tailwind v3
you can now use an arbitrary value to generate one of transition property on the fly, sowas
da, jetzt wirds aber richtig 5 hat time-ig langsam, dann einfach so transition, boah,
heute ist animated, es animiert, transition, guck mal, pog, das ist ja easy, easy as fuck,
ist das nicht massive pog, easy as fuck, easy as fuck, easy as fuck, easy as fuck, easy
as fuck, nice, easy, das ist ja cool, damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet ehrlich gesagt,
guck mal hier, wie nice, jetzt müssen wir nur noch, Leute, jetzt müssen wir nur noch
diesen hässlichen scroll wegkriegen, lasst mal meine css skills walten, resize, none,
ok jetzt ist unten dieser komische resize weg, overflow, over scroll, overflow, clip hidden,
was ist der Unterschied zwischen clip und hidden, 1337, das hab ich mich bis jetzt noch
nicht gefragt, so nice, guck mal hier, aha, ich hab einen bug gefunden, aber guck mal,
ich kann nicht mal mit der maus scrollen jetzt, maus scrollen geht nicht mehr, und das ist
zu hoch, das sieht eklig aus, haben wir h8, h7, h8, h9, hä, eben, what the fuck, ok jetzt
wirds advanced, jetzt müssen wir rausfinden, wie man die scrollleiste ausschaltet, ohne
den eigentlichen overflow auszuschalten, google fragen, maus scroll overflow, irgendwie sowas,
but should enable mouse scrolling, siehst du, stack overflow weiß Bescheid, was overflow
auto, das glaub ich nicht, aber wenn der chat das sagt, probier ichs mal, äh bringt nix,
da braucht man bestimmt wieder irgendwelche special css hacks für unterschiedliche browser,
scroll bar width, ok im moment, das probier maus, scroll bar hat tailwind nicht, also
style scroll bar width, none gibts nicht, äh kann ich einfach sagen null, ne das bringt
nix, unset, none, nö geht nicht, das geht nicht, vielleicht geht das nur im firefox,
aber im firefox muss ich jetzt erstmal irgendwas eintragen, ah ja guck mal im firefox funktioniert
das, im chrome gehts nicht, das ist wieder so ein zwischending zwischen chrome und firefox
extrawurst, ok, ähm wir fragen, wir fragen die hier, was, was, was, nein, ah moment da
war doch was, guck mal, webkit scroll bar, gibts da nicht irgendwas für alle, wir brauchen
bessere suchbegriffe, maus, scroll, overflow hidden, stack overflow, äh, stack overflow,
hide scroll bar, overflow y hidden, ja aber dann geht die maus auch weiterhin nicht, oder,
wenn ich jetzt sag, overflow y hidden, ne da geht die maus ja nicht, das ist ja der witz,
ich will ja weiter mit der maus scrollen können, hide scroll bar, but while still being able
to scroll, exakt das brauch ich, stack overflow, ah yes, i, nein, das da will ich haben, genau
das, webkit scroll bar, webkit, ne, das ist jetzt aber nur für webkit, aha, hier guck
mal, internet explorer, firefox und für safari und chrome, exellent, das brauchen wir, da
nicht container, das nennen wir jetzt irgendwie scroll bar off oder so, dann so, und jetzt
schreiben wir das da ran, scroll bar off, ha, und geht das scroll noch, und das maus spiel
scrollen funktioniert leute, eckermans wieder am start hier, wir haben gewonnen, wir haben
gewonnen, auf touch geräten, äh, können wir ausprobieren, ob es auf touch geräten
funktioniert, ihr könnt es selbst ausprobieren, ich deploy das mal schnell, deploy champ, playbook,
achso, äh, welcher ip hat unseren surfer gekriegt, zack, ja, ich, ich deploy mal schnell,
ok, ist deployed, auf gehts, to do services, ich machs mal auf dem iphone auf und guck mir
das ganze an, to do, cac with services, mein iphone hat es immer noch gecashed, ok, das
funzt, leute es funzt auf dem iphone richtig gut, das funktioniert auf dem iphone fast besser
als aufm, äh, als aufm desktop, weil es richtig, weil es richtig schön smooth scrolled, richtig
spork, das funktioniert richtig gut aufm iphone, nice, sehr schön, so, dann sollten wir vielleicht
noch ne andere sachen machen, wenn ein neues to do angelegt wird, oh, jetzt hab ich, jetzt
hab ich irgendwie zu viel gelöscht gerade, das war nicht so schlau, cac wait, wahrscheinlich
war die animation zu lang und deswegen hab ich jetzt was falsches gelöscht, aber eigentlich
muss das doch nur ausfahren, wenn multiline text ist oder, wie jetzt, es fährt doch, achso,
du meinst nur wenn wir mehrere zeilen text haben, ja dann müsste ich irgendwie heraus
bekommen, ob da mehrere zeilen text drinstehen, das ist glaub ich gar nicht so einfach, das
müsste eigentlich nur so weit ausfahren, wie wir textzeilen haben, das ist in der tats
glaube ich jetzt gar nicht so einfach rauszubekommen, wie viele textzeilen wir haben, das hängt
von der schriftart ab, dem browser, der auflösung, das ist tatsächlich nicht so easy, dann lieber
so, cac wait, cac wait, cac wait, wait, wait, wait, cac wait, was auf brave ist die tastatur
danach kaputt, ja, brave lul, who cares brave, aber das find ich ein nice feature, guck mal
während das ein und aus fährt, ist es verbugged, da kann man nichts anderes anklicken, warum?
wahrscheinlich, weil beim klicken die maus dann schon wieder weg ist, kaputt, man kann
es nicht anklicken, man kann es auch nicht löschen, während es wieder einfährt, das
ist kein so schönes feature, aber gut, dafür ist es cool zu sehen, wie das ein und aus
fährt, so jetzt müssen wir es nur noch hinkriegen, dass wenn man ein neues to do anlegt, das
nicht leer ist, so, neues to do, default to dos hatten wir hier irgendwo, neue default
to dos ist der text nicht leer, sondern, keine ahnung, title, ja wunderbar, guck mal, man
kann nur löschen, man kann nur löschen, wenn es wieder eingefahren ist, so, nice, kicks
to do for the win hier, google design award 2002, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es sowas gibt,
ich bewerb mich beim deutschen computerspiele preis, das ist zwar kein spiel, aber da kriegt
eh jeder irgendwas, egal wie schlecht es ist, da muss man sich nur noch überlegen, warum
das ein spiel ist, und man muss irgendwie eine pädagogisch wertvolle message vermitteln,
dass man da gewinnt, da müssen wir uns irgendwas ausdenken, warum ich mich damit beim deutschen
computerspiele preis bewerben kann, es ist wichtig, dass man sich in seinem leben die
zeit gut einteilt, und deswegen gibt es die kicks to do app, die dafür sorgt, dass Kinder
die hausaufgaben pünktlich erledigen, oder irgendein blödsinn, ein schwachsinn, da wird
man bestimmt beim deutschen computerspiele preis angelockt, so, park, kunst, huge animation,
ich muss euch mal sagen, dafür, dass ich das design einfach random aus vorgefertigten
tailwind klassen zusammengeklickt habe, sieht das von der farbgebung her gar nicht so scheiße
aus im dark theme, oder, ich finde das sieht sogar mit dem grau, und auch mit dem pink,
ich finde das sieht sogar relativ stylisch aus, so, was sollten wir jetzt noch machen,
lass mal überlegen, wir könnten noch die checkbox, pass mal auf, checkbox, hover, animate, animate
pulse, guck mal, wenn es über die checkbox geht, dann macht die checkbox richtig hyper
gachi, mach doch in light mode, das problem ist, wenn ich in light mode mache, da muss
ich mir für alles neue farben ausdenken, da habe ich kein bock drauf, es fehlt fortnite,
wie soll ich das mit fortnite in verbindung bringen, wäre es vielleicht sinnvoll, wenn
das immer oben bleibt und nicht mit ausfährt, chat was meint ihr, wäre das sinnvoll, wenn
die dinger immer oben allein bleiben würden, oder dass sie mit ausfahren, und die to do's
trennen, könnte man ja durch den extra strich nochmal, das machen wir mal, also nach jedem
to do, nach jedem to do was der rendert, machen wir einen strich, ich glaube nicht, dass sowas
gut aussieht oder, aber wir können an das diff gehen und sagen unten, border, bottom
oder sowas, falls das geht, 2 pixel, nee, warte mal, und dann muss man sagen was, border,
width oder was, ah, bottom, bottom, width, 2 pixel, ach quatsch, wir sind ja nicht zuerst,
wir sind ja tailwind, wir sind ja im tailwind, nee moment, hä, sekunde, wo bin ich denn
hier gelandet jetzt, warum habe ich hier noch inline style, das ist ja komplett beknackt,
hä, was habe ich denn da gemacht, war das, ist das noch übrig von bevor wir tailwind
eingebunden haben, das ist ja richtig bescheuert, nee, dann müssen wir das anders machen, class,
flex, align, nee, wie war das, item center und dann padding, padding, bottom, irgendwie
2 oder so in dem fall, lass mal kurz gucken, oh, was habe ich jetzt verpasst, was ja, item
center ist falsch, doch align, item center, was ist jetzt der unterschied dazwischen,
das müsste doch beides mehr oder weniger, ach da ist ein semi colon drin, ah, jetzt passt,
ok, eigentlich können wir das padding weglassen, ich habe jetzt gelernt, es gibt sowas wie
gap, guck mal, bei flexbox, es gibt sowas wie gap, wusste ich bis gestern nicht, dass
es sowas gibt und nachdem ich das jetzt gelernt habe, dass es sowas gibt, könnte man eigentlich
hier wieder die abstände rausnehmen, die ich aber gar nicht finde, habe ich die hier gar
nicht drin, hier margin 2, nee das sieht kacke aus, dann lasse ich das mit dem gap bleiben,
dann lasse ich das jetzt so, wunderbar, was wollte ich jetzt machen, unter jedes to do
ein strich, ne, also border minus 2, ok border bottom, nee border, wie macht man nur unten
ein border in, ach border minus b ist das jetzt oder was, das hätte man aber auch bisschen
schöner benennen können, also da würde ich ja im leben ja nicht drauf kommen, ok das
sieht rounded, sieht hängen geblieben aus, so was machen wir da jetzt für eine farbe,
ich würde sagen wir nehmen die gleiche farbe, die war, oh, das sieht doch eigentlich ganz
ok aus jetzt, nur dass das letzte to do jetzt auch unten was hat, das ist dumm, oder das
sieht hässlich aus, da bräuchte ich jetzt noch irgendwie next level logik um das zu
fixen, da hält mir jetzt grad nix ein wenn ich ehrlich bin, Vue.js ist mit abstand des
geiles, ja ich verwende eigentlich auch für fast alles Vue.js, aber, ich wollte mal was
anderes ausprobieren, last child, ach last, boah die leute, der chat wieder, alter warum
ist mein chat so high iq, ach ich weiß, weil alle so prime subscribt haben in der vergangenheit
schon, der chat ist einfach wieder massive brained, guckt euch mal so last, ne, ging das
so, last, ach so, ach ne, es ist border 2 und bei last ist es border 0, ah, oh, ne, oder
auch nicht, warum nicht, dein folgetauschen, meinst du das macht was, ne, macht nichts,
der scope ist falsch, ja da hört es bei mir jetzt auf mit css, da reicht mein gehirn
nicht mal dafür jetzt, was ist wenn ich sag last border 2, moment, der scope, ja ja der
scope ist falsch, ich weiß nicht wo der hin muss, ah, aber, ne, das hier ist doch das
flex, das li ist doch nicht mal last, hä, was es muss bei der liste hin, wie jetzt wirklich,
da, das kann aber noch nicht funktionieren, ne, falsch, da, oh, ok, ähm, nein, no pass,
so geht das nicht und außerdem, wenn schon, bezieht sich das doch auf das flex oder, da
bin ich nicht high iq für das hier zu checken, wenn dann auf dem li, ok, wenn der chat das
sagt, dann glaube ich im chat das, hey, alter, massive brain der chat wieder, ok, dann brauchen
wir jetzt noch border grey 500, border grey 500, sag, wunderbar exquisite, komm mal, jetzt
haben wir ein animiertes, ein animiertes löschen button, einen pulsierenden abhaken knopf und
ein ein und aus fadendes textding, das ist ja poggers, so und jetzt ist die frage, wie
kriege ich die dinger nach oben aligned, als web-entwickler endlich mal den urlauben max
zuschauen, ja, kannst du dich ein bisschen kaputt lachen, wie ich die einfachsten css
dinger nicht checke, gibt es jemand, der so css dinger checkt überhaupt, ich sehe auch
immer auf youtube die leute massig schneiden, wenn sie zum css part kommen in ihren tutorials,
also normalerweise kannst du die leuten ganz gut zugucken, wenn die irgendwelche logik
programmieren, das geht dann relativ flüssig und weniger schritte, weniger schnitte, kaum
kommen die zum css part, gibt es zwei varianten, entweder sagen sie, ich hab da mal was vorbereitet
und pasten einfach mal kurz so irgendwie 250 zeilen rein und sagen, so, das ist jetzt
das css was wir brauchen, ihr müsst euch nicht weiter Gedanken zu machen oder sie schneiden
nach jeder zweiten zeile css, weil sie nachgucken müssen, so diese zwei tutorials kommen mir
öfters unter, so, was wollte ich denn jetzt machen, dann hab ich vergessen, was ich machen
wollte, ah, dass das oben allein bleibt, wie kriege ich das oben allein, das ist irgendeine
flexbox-geschichte, leute, ich muss mal kurz, ich muss euch mal kurz muten, ich muss mal
mein headset entknoten, das backt rum, das backt massiv an der seite rum, so, ok, jetzt
müssen wir irgendwie gucken, wie man das hier, so zum besseren testen, zum besseren testen
machen wir mal die, oh die auch H40, so, wie kriegen wir die Dinge oben aligned, items
start, items, ach meinste oben beim flex oder hier, also anscheinend items start, nee, warum
hab ich die noch mal gesendert, aha, guck mal da, pogge, yep, so jetzt müssen wir das
nur noch ein bisschen nach unten ausrichten, dann passt das alles, margin top 2, ach so,
die sind auch so nicht ganz gerade, was hatten wir da vorher, 8, wegen der margin hier, ah,
und jetzt, und jetzt können wir hier flex, yep, 2, margin top 4, naaah, margin 2, ja,
so ist doch alles ganz ok, ach stimmt, margin y, das gibt es ja auch noch, oh poggers, poggers,
das zwar nicht ganze line, aber das wird sich nicht ändern lassen, weil das eine schriftgröße
liegt, nice, extrem nice, hier, das wird aber ganz schön unübersichtlich nach einer Zeit,
oder, wenn hier so ein tailwind Ding aus 50 Milliarden Sachen steht, hier padding, warum
hab ich hier ein padding drin, weil, eigentlich will ich nicht padding 1 haben, was, wie sieht
es mit padding 0 aus, padding y1 wieder, nee, x, nee, padding 0, und dann, padding left 2,
ja, das ist doch ganz gut, und jetzt können wir das glaube ich noch, 1 kleiner mal, ah,
yes, aber so ist es eigentlich besser, so, wunderbar, jetzt ist das mal wirklich next
level shit, oh guck mal, jetzt kann man nämlich auch oben klicken, während das expanded ist,
das funktioniert jetzt, sollte das nicht wieder nach oben kommen automatisch, warum kommt
es nicht wieder automatisch nach oben beim rendern jetzt, na gut, woher auch, jetzt wieder
ein outtake, hä, was, ich wollte mit dem fabian ein video aufnehmen, der hat aber erst morgens
zeit, oder über morgens, glaube ich, erst, die haben nämlich, dem Fabian haben sie nämlich
das internet abgeschaltet, passend zu Weihnachten, beste stelle, beste Jahreszeit, er, ist natürlich
wieder fail, aber kann er ja nix für, statement, ein stream, was, on stream gefurzt, alter,
ihr habt auch wieder alles mitgeschnitten, oder, ok, das ist doch kein furz, das ist,
wenn die Jacke, das ist, wenn die Jacke am, hier, das ist, wenn die Jacke am mikrofon
kratzt, ist das, das ist kein furz, und selbst wenn, und selbst wenn, dass man da so genau
drauf achten, ist ja auch schon wieder so ein ding, aber das ist hier, habt ihr grad gehört,
das ist die Jacke, die ich an hab am mikrofon, so, richtig, richtig, jetzt soll ich deployen,
deployen, leute, dass ihr auch euch die neuste version angucken könnt, ansible playbook
deploy, jawoll, ich mein, wisst ihr, was wir uns noch, was, wisst ihr, was wir uns noch
merken könnten, nach was sollten die to do's sortiert sein, eigentlich nach erstellungsdatum,
oder, ne, ne, ich will nicht dumb to do's oben, ich will to do's oben, die als erstes
erstellt wurden, was meint ihr, ist es sinnvoll, also im angenommen, ich mach das hier jetzt,
ding, dann geht's runter, und wenn ich's jetzt hier anklicke, dann geht's halt nicht wieder
hoch, nach wichtigkeit, ja, aber die dinge haben keine priorität, man hat keine möglichkeiten
aktuell prioritäten zu vergeben, und ich wüsste auch krass aus dem stegreifen nicht,
wo ich da irgendwas für prioritäten noch einbauen sollte, man könnt es nach erstelldatum
sortieren, vielleicht, oder man könnte sich auch interessanteren features widmen als so
kleinen optimierungskram, ne, na, drag and drop, drag and drop ist wirklich nicht einfach,
priorität entscheidet eine ai, das ist es, leute, wir lassen big brain, blockchain, data
science, ai, das entscheiden, wo unsere to do's hinkommen, so, ähm, lass mal kurz in
mich gehen, sortiere nach due date, ja, aber es gibt kein due date, oder gibt es einen
coolen, moment, swelled date time picker, gibt es da irgendwie einen coolen swelled date
time picker, lightweight date time picker, mit crit stack gs, es vergeht auch keinen
tag wo es neue javascript frameworks gibt, oder, es gibt einen default vom browser, stimmt,
warte mal, browser date, oder irgendwie date time picker, wie sieht denn der aus, der ist
bestimmt hässlich, oder, that default date time picker, da kann man überhaupt nix picken,
input date time, deprecated, warum ist das deprecated, was soll man anstatt dessen, this
feature has no current browser implementation, naja, also wisst ihr was, es gibt schlimmeres,
es gibt wirklich schlimmeres als diesen date time picker, oder, ok, firefox, firefox hat
ich gedacht wir brauchen keinen date time picker, ah doch hier, ich mein es ist keine
augenweite, aber so hässlich ist es doch jetzt auch nicht, also der schlimmste, der schlimmste
date time picker ist der hier, ich mag beautify, aber das mag ich überhaupt nicht, guckt euch
das mal an, monkaS, das ist material design shit, aber, naja, beim besten will ich nicht,
das mag ich überhaupt gar nicht, ok, also was muss man, input gleich date time local,
dann probieren wir das doch mal aus, wir machen einfach hier mal den input hin, ihh, kann
man den, kann man den stylen, wahrscheinlich nicht, ne, das ist wieder so ein ding was
man nicht richtig stylen kann, bg, naja, naja, das popup kann man nicht stylen, ja gut, why
not, sag mal gibt es auch, gibt es die möglichkeit da einfach nur das hier anzuzeigen, nur, nur
on popup, weil dafür habe ich überhaupt keinen platz, ich bräuchte einen button, der nur
das icon anzeigt und dann das hier, das hier öffnet, ehh, date time local icon only, change
date time input, was für ein ding, wat, ne, ne, remove calendar icon, ne, ne, ne, ich will
nur das calendar icon haben, input type date, das ist eklig, mach doch eine sortierung nach
erstelldatum oder oder ablaufdatum, ja, ablaufdatum will ich ja gerade setzen, die sache ist,
wie kriege ich den date time picker so hin, dass er nur das icon anzeigt, ich mein was
ich machen könnte ist, ehh, was war die frage eben leute, was in, in was für einem programm
schreibt man einen solchen code, ehh, in dem fall, in dem fall ist es wishlist studio code,
aber muss es nicht sein, du kannst das in jedem x beliebigen editor programmieren, aber
es bietet sich in dem fall an wishlist studio code zu verwenden, weil es relativ viele plugins
hat und hört nicht auf den chat mit vim, ich bin vim fan, was kommandozeilen editieren
angeht, aber sowas bräuchte ich nicht, input date time local, ich mein was man machen könnte,
was aber wahrscheinlich nicht schön ist, man könnte sagen, ehhm, breite 2, breite 4, breite
8, was weiß ich 20, so, guck mal man könnte, man könnte die breite so machen, dass am ende,
ihh, das geht aber dann unter firefox nicht richtig, ich glaube das funktioniert nicht
gescheit, mir fällt nicht ein, wie ich diesen date time picker, gescheit da rein basteln
sollte, mic diet, dankeschön für den sub, ok, da bin ich, da bin ich zu noobig für,
das ist auch nicht, das ist auch nicht, ehhm, einheitlich genug irgendwie, könnte man, ne,
wir nehmen eben den fertigen date time picker, komm wir gucken mal was es da gibt, ich hab
doch eben gesucht, ich hab doch eben gesucht, hier guck mal svelte kalender, svelte date
time picker, 11 tage zuletzt aktualisiert, demo, ich brauch ne demo, demo, with time,
with time, choose date, ok, das liegt an meinem darkreel, dass das kacke aussieht, range picker,
ich will, ich will eigentlich, ich will ohne date, wobei ne, ne, ich will date time picker,
aber das funktioniert dann wieder unter ios kacke, ist denn wenigstens das ding, das muss
ich jetzt, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausbringen leute, ist denn wenigstens das ding hier unter
ios dann der native date time picker, wenn ich das einblende, ich push das mal kurz,
ich push das mal kurz und wir probieren, ihr könnt das dann auch ausprobieren hier, ja,
ok, probier mal aus, hier date time picker, probier ich das mal auf dem iphone aus, das
ist der native, weil der native date time picker brauchst du für ios, sonst, sonst checkts
keiner mehr, äh, das service geht bei mir grade nicht auf dem, auf dem handy, warum
bin ich, irgendwie lädt das bei mir nicht, ist mein wlan down oder so, nö, äh, ok,
ich weiß nicht warum, aber auf meinem iphone lädts nicht, aber wenn ihr sagt, das ist
der native date time picker, dann ist ja, ist ja alles in ordnung, Leute ich hab keine
gute idee dafür, wie wir das mit date time machen sollen, ich mein ich bräuchte, warum
geht denn das nicht, warum geht auf meinem iphone diese seite nicht mehr, grade vorhin
da ging sie noch, keine ahnung, auf meinem iphone gehts nicht mal auf, unsichtbares input
mit externem button, ist das mit swell direkt responsive, naja, so wie ichs gebaut hab, ist
es halt so responsive wie es geht, so größer hier, kriegst nen größeren button, haben
eine gewisse größe und ansonsten bleibt das relativ responsive, also es ist responsive
bis auf diese größe runter, ich glaub das reicht sogar für ein altes nokia handy, nee
also das gefällt mir immer gar nicht mit dem date time picker hier, ich mein wir könnten
nen button machen, funktioniert dann sowas hier, würde dann sowas funktionieren, dass
ich den date time picker trigger über nen extra button, das sagen wir mal zum testen,
machen wir das mal zum testen, ich mach jetzt einfach mal nen button hier hin zum ausprobieren,
oder hier plus, so, das ist button, so und dann machen wir nen hidden date time, und jetzt
trigger ich über diesen button den date time, so wie mach ich das überhaupt, nee nee nee
class hidden, nee nee nee das bringt nix, ähm class hidden ist schon ok, aber ich will
ja, ich will ja das hier triggern, wisst ihr was wir machen das jetzt nicht hier für
alles, das hab ich noch nie gemacht, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, das machen wir hier einmal
oben, dass ich weiß wo wir sind, nee nee nee class remove blinkt auch nix, ich will doch
nicht diesen scheiß anzeigen, ich will das hier triggern, das, ich will quasi n click
simulieren oder sowas, also id picker, machen wir mal die klassische, machen wir mal die
klassische javascript variante, ähm, keine ahnung, äh trigger, nehmen wir den jetzt
einfach mal, was jetzt, direct, achso, ja, das ist auch doof, dass man da immer diese
komischen klammern drum braucht, so, äh, function, trigger, keine parameter, so, document get
element by id, picker, mal gucken ob das funktioniert, was ich da gestrickt hab, das ist aber bestimmt
nicht das swelled way, das kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen, ok, das funktioniert und jetzt
click, click, das funktioniert nicht, ok, datetime local trigger button, how to trigger,
you can hide most of the input content and keep styling the calendar using css classes
for shadow dom, ok, ok, das ist richtiger paints champ gerade, ok nice, wie sieht denn
das in firefox jetzt aus, ist klar, dass sind ja auch die webkit dinger, ich, das ding muss
man doch triggern können, ok, wir gucken jetzt mal bei mozilla, was das ding für events
hat, das problem ist das ding sieht in jedem browser anders aus, was hat das ding für
events, change input list, select step down step up, you have only change and input events
events ist nichts für mich zum klicken, event ist das was ausgelöst wird wenn es passiert
nicht um es zu triggern, ja gut, das ist eine stack overflow kopie, der hat das einfach
gerippt, das stack overflow ding, pack das gibt es nicht, ok, jetzt weiß ich auch warum
die alle custom date time picker verwenden, weil das paints champ nicht hoch 10 ist, sag
mal warum geht dann bitte schön in meinem handy meine webseite nicht mehr auf, ist das
ok, ne das funktioniert nicht gescheit, ne also sowas gibt es hier nicht, ok, click geht
bei mir nicht, click chrome desktop, ne funktioniert bei mir nicht, ok, das ist richtig cancer,
ne ne ne, das machen wir nicht, das machen wir nicht, da brauchen wir irgendeinen fertigen
date time picker und am liebsten hätte ich halt einen date time picker der dann in ios
auch ordentlich funktioniert, das ist halt schon richtig eklig, was ist aus dem preischamp
geworden, der preischamp da wird wohl Ende des jahres abgeschaltet, ne das funktioniert
so nicht, aber das ist ja eklig, das ist ja eklig, dass das nicht standard ist, ok was
hatten wir hier nochmal, ihr mein der scheint mir doch ganz in ordnung zu sein hier, mit
time, wie kann ich hier die time auswählen, continue alter, boah ist das abartig, alter
ne ne das ist ja mega hässlich das ding, ne wird ja immer schlimmer, ne ne das verwende
ich nicht, ne gibt es nicht, gebt kein due date, due date is overrated, she baited outdated,
das machen wir nicht, wir machen ein created date, wir machen created, plat picker, ich
bräuchte nen picker der auf ios das native element verwendet, ich weiß gar nicht wie
das native element aussieht auf ios, weil mein handy der meinung ist er lädt die seite
einfach nicht, warte mal ich mach jetzt einfach mein chrome auf, ich mach jetzt mal chrome
auf und gucke ob es da drin geht bei mir auf dem handy, no thanks, todo.caqv.services,
warum zum teufel geht auf einmal auf meinem iphone meine eigene app nicht mehr, ich ändere
mal den dns, mein dns hat bestimmt mist gecached, wifi, info dns, configure dns, manual, add
server, nennen wir mal google hier, 8.8.8.8, delete den standard server ok, jetzt gehts
wieder, mein dns hat mist gecached, ja und der ios ist der date time picker wunderbar,
den will ich ja verwenden, ich will den standard ios date time picker verwenden wenn ich die
möglichkeit habe und überall anders und gerade auf dem desktop, ok was hat irgendjemand gesagt,
demo, flat picker, org.js, examples, date time picker, naja, augenweite ist es jetzt
auch nicht gerade, aber ganz ok, das ist wirklich ein komplexes thema hätte ich nicht gedacht,
das schreibe ich mal in die featureliste unter advanced, date time picker due date, das sieht
man mal wenn die websachen nicht standardisiert sind dann ist es eklig, kannst du das projekt
auf github packen, ja kann ich machen, oh guck mal das buggt immer noch ein bisschen, was
ist hier los, warum buggt das delete, hä hä, ok, hm, not not sure if serious, warum buggen
das delete rum, direkt weniger zu tun, ja, vielleicht wegen meinem rumgesorte hier, das
ist nicht stimmt, wobei nee, das muss funktionieren, ich glaube ich weiß was es ist, ich glaube
irgendwie ist mein filter wahrscheinlich nicht richtig, ich, wobei ich mache eine neue liste
mit to do's, die nicht die id haben, ah, nee id++, ach so, ich speicher die id, ok ich
habe den bug gefunden leute, der bug ist richtig dumm, guck mal, meine id fängt immer bei
1 an, aber wenn ich die seite reloade fängt die id wieder bei 1 an und wenn ich die adde
habe ich jetzt mehrfach to do's mit der gleichen id, ok das ist glaube ich etwas low iq, oi,
was gibt es da zwischen für schöne möglichkeiten als id zu verwenden, gibt es eine möglichkeit
im browser, irgendwie, browser, gen, irgendwie sowas, how to create guid im browser, bleh,
kripto random ui, ok, ok, moment, moment, wie geht das jetzt, was, kripto, ui, nee,
htps, ernsthaft, ich kann doch nicht mal lokal mit nem server das entwickeln oder was, supporting
browsers und alle supporten es, außer, außer natürlich, was sonst, wer supportet es wieder
nicht, wer könnte es sein, wer es nicht supportet, na, 3 mal dürft ihr raten, wer ist es, es
Warum ist Apple so kacke unter iOS was Browser angeht?
Das ist wirklich Ethernet Explorer 2.0 das Ding.
Das ist ganz ganz grausam, dazu kann man bloß sagen PISS DICH ALDO!
Gibt es da eine gute Möglichkeit UNIQ-IDs im Browser zu generieren?
Ich meine ansonsten speichere ich mir einfach die ID im Local Storage, aber schön ist was
anderes, weil wenn ich die Dinger verschicke, ne ne das wäre schon praktisch wenn das UNIQ
ID nicht wäre, haben die vielleicht was eingebaut?
Jawoll schön und wie generiert er das?
UUID und wo kommt das her?
Anja Kowalska, ah hier das ist das Package, External Resources und woher weiß ich jetzt
welche Library das hier ist?
Gar nicht.
Ah hier, NPM Installer, ich will wissen was das für ein Package ist, taugt das was?
Okay es hat 11,8K Sterne, das kann schon mal nicht so schlecht sein, okay das verwenden
wir jetzt, NPM Installer, auf gehts BAM, NEIN, ähm etwas falsche, wo hat er das jetzt installiert?
Edit One Package, wo genau hat er jetzt das Package geedit?
Hab ich jetzt in meinem Heimatverzeichnis irgendeine Package chasen oder so?
Genau das ist das was ich wollte unbedingt, ja so siehts aus, okay NPM Installer, nein
NPM Installer, ah ja, so jetzt aber, gut, RUN DEV, okay, der Browser ist wieder Zugang,
na gut, warum, Localhost 3000, okay also was muss man da jetzt importen, import V4 SUUID
V4, alles klar wird gemacht, BAM, hat gefunzt und jetzt SUUID V4, log, log, okay scheint
zu funzen Leute, okay das verwenden wir jetzt als ID, muss man das sieden oder macht es
wirklich das immer korrekt, ja anscheinend passt das, na gut, also dann machen wir das
jetzt ein bisschen anders, wir nehmen für unsere To Do's als ID, ich lösch das mal,
wo hab ich hier ID, ID kommt weg und wir nehmen für unsere ID's lieber den Kram hier, zack,
wisst ihr was ich jetzt nochmal ausprobieren, wie hoch die Chance ist, dass der, also manche
Implementierungen die auf random oder gerade auch auf Time Seeds basieren sind halt ein
bisschen kacke, dass wenn du zu schnell ID's generierst, dass es dann doppelt rauskommt,
aber ey ich meine wenn die Library 12.000 Sterne hat, wir glauben jetzt einfach mal,
dass sie das ordentlich machen, easy, was soll schon schief gehen, so hat er das jetzt gespeichert,
zeig mal hier, Application, Application Local Storage To Do's, ID, warum ist da immer
noch eine ID mit 4 drinne, weg damit, was soll das hier, jetzt haben wir die richtige
ID, jetzt passt das, jetzt haben wir Sachen mit ordentlicher ID drinne, Poggers, so muss
das sein, so muss das sein, das ist doch schon mal gleich viel besser als doppelte, so und
jetzt haben wir auch nicht das Problem, dass wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwas anlege und ich
dann die Seite reloade, dass er dann Sachen doppeln löscht, genau, sehr gut, da haben
wir das doch schon mal gefixt, behoben, easy, alles klar, so hätten wir das schon mal,
wo sind wir eigentlich jetzt ursprünglich stehen geblieben bei der ganzen Geschichte,
wobei, nee wir haben es doch hingekriegt, guck mal, die Sachen stehen jetzt oben, passt doch,
das sieht doch jetzt richtig gut aus, nicht, dass man es sinnvoll verwenden würde, aber
von der Idee her ist doch eigentlich ganz nice, so und jetzt wollten wir noch erstelldatum
rein machen, nachdem man das sortieren kann, also machen wir sowas wie, was ist die richtige
JavaScript Schreibweise dafür, wie machen das die coolen JavaScript Leute, Created at
oder Created at oder Created at oder, wie ist da, wie ist da die korrekte Schreibweise
bei, bei, bei den JavaScript 5 hats, einfach nur Created, ok, man spart sichs einfach,
dann umgeht das Problem, das ist auch ne gute Idee, ok, date, now, wie krieg ich ein Timestamp,
wie krieg ich ein Timestamp seit 1900, irgendetwas, weil ich will wahrscheinlich nicht date now
haben, weil date now ist ja im Zweifelsfall Zeit, wobei ist das schlimm, wenn das Zeitzonen
abhängig ist, eigentlich nicht, oder doch, ja Timestamp seit 1970 ist besser, js datetime
1970, wie geht das, die Zeit vergangen könntest du auch als UID nehmen, das stimmt, das ist
ne gute Idee, da würden wir zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe erschlagen, ich muss grad mal
kurz was checken, node, date, Punkt now, Moment, das sind doch Sekunden, hä, ich dachte das
gibt nen Zeitobjekt zurück, das gibt wirklich einfach nur Sekunden zurück, Millisekunden,
ich glaub es sind sogar Millisekunden seit 1970, anscheinend, MSI, convert, ja, das sind
tatsächlich Millisekunden, das könnte man, ich mein, ich geh mal davon aus, dass keiner
es schafft in der gleichen Millisekunde zwei To Do's anzulegen, oder, ich mein, man traut
den Leuten ja viel zu, aber, warte was, man nimmt Timestamps vergangen seit 1970, ja,
man nimmt Timestamps seit 1970, also Sekunden oder Millisekunden vergangen seit 1970, seit
1.1.1970, das ist Unix-Time nennt sich das, Unix-Time ist quasi 1.1.1970, Unix-Zeit zählt
die vergangenen Sekunden seit Donnerstag dem ersten Januar 1970, UTC, warum 1970, weil
man sich das so ausgedacht hat, weil man das so festgelegt hat, ich weiß nicht ob das
einen tieferen Sinn hat, dass es jetzt genau 1970 ist und nicht 1975 oder so, oder 1969,
ok Created Date Time Now haben wir jetzt auch, so das ist die Default To Do's, da brauch
ich hier noch Created, so, wunderbar und jetzt haben wir sogar was nachdem man das ganze
sortieren kann, man könnte jetzt natürlich auch mal irgendwie so ne Funktion machen,
so was wie Create To Do, und der übergibt man dann quasi Text, der muss man ja nur Text
übergeben, das ist ja easy, dann kann ich mir nämlich den ganzen Spaß hier sparen,
ok, 1969++, ja das geht auch, so, Return, Text, Chat hat irgendjemand nen Plan ob das
funktioniert in JavaScript, wenn Text leerer String ist oder Null, dann soll Any Primers
reingeschrieben werden, geht das so, mal gucken ob das funktioniert, so und jetzt muss ich
sagen hier Create To Do und jetzt hier an der Stelle auch wieder Create To Do, bloß
dann mit dem, äh, Title, wobei Any Primers ist es dumm das so reinzuschreiben, das kommt
da recht unerwartet, so, so, hey funktioniert, die Funktion nicht im JSON Pass, hä, doch
ist sie drin, ne ist sie nicht, doch ist sie, ok das ist ein bisschen dumm umgebrochen,
ah Moment, warte mal jetzt bin ich verwirrt, JSON Pass, ne das muss nicht ins JSON Pass
sein, warte mal jetzt bin ich, hä, Moment was hab ich denn da vorher gemacht, was war
mein Default, ach ich hab das JSON String Fight noch, ok, ähm, kann ich das hier einfach
rausnehmen, ergibt das da noch Sinn, ja aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das funktioniert
wenn ich das, wenn ich das rausnehme, weil wenn es das hier nicht gibt, moin Tromm, wenn
es das hier nicht gibt, dann brauch ich irgendein Default To Do, also wenn es Get Item nicht
gibt, dann brauch ich ein leeres Array, so, und dann musste ich danach checken, if leeres
Array, wisst ihr was, easy, wir machen den JSON String um ihn danach wieder zu passen,
so ist das richtig, so jetzt gucken wir uns das nicht weiter an, mal alles löschen, gucken
ob es funktioniert, ja, ne, passt, ok das ist auch noch ein Bug, ist ja auch egal, das
ignorier ich jetzt einfach, so Any Primers Fragezeichen, seit wann programmierst du,
boah, schon lange seit, also angefangen hab ich mit C-Sharp 2002 oder so, aber Javascript
ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so mein Steckenpferd, kann man doch glaube ich kurz zu sagen, uns
Welt hab ich vor zwei Tagen angefangen, deswegen mach ich auch ne To Do App, weil wir ja wissen,
To Do Apps sind quasi die Hello Worlds der Webentwicklung, so auf uns das jetzt was wir
hier gebaut haben, machen wir mal neues Tab auf, öffnen das und wir sehen es ist kaputt,
ich hab's verkackt, es ist kaputt, bam, unrecoverable error, weil To Do's Filter is not a Function
RIP, warum nicht, was hab ich kaputt gemacht, warum geht es jetzt nicht, ne das liegt nicht
am Incognito Tab, warum hab ich's jetzt kaputt, was hab ich zerstört, aha, ok jetzt wird's
aber richtig hässlich, aber jetzt funktioniert's, sehr gut, exellent, das ist ja wirklich eines
der hässlichsten Dinge aller Zeiten, wisst ihr was, einfach easy, kommt mal, bam, jetzt
erkennt es keiner mehr, jetzt ist alles super beautiful, ich hab aber durch das ganze hin
und her jetzt schon wieder komplett verdrängt, wo ich eigentlich gerade dabei war, achso
ja der Bug, achja sortieren nach Created, genau, sortieren nach Created, ok jetzt müsste, wenn
ich das nach Created sortieren müsste das nach oben kommen, warum ist eigentlich Javascript
sort so kacke, so ich will's sortieren nach Created und dann nach dann nicht dann, ne umgedreht
oder, ne, ne, so rum ist richtig, so rum ist richtig, ne, ne passt, wie sortier ich denn
jetzt nach DateTime, sort DateTime, warum gibt es nicht, sag mal, gibt es nicht irgendeine
gescheite Javascript Library mit so paar Extention Sachen, wo man zum Beispiel ordentliche Suche
hat, wo ich dann sowas hier machen kann, sort, buy und dann irgendwie einfach nur angeben
kann to do's, Created oder sowas, weil das ist ja wirklich abartig, guckt euch das mal
an, simplest answer, new date, be date, minus new, what, ahhh Javascript please, Created,
es funktioniert, es funktioniert, aber schön ist was anderes und ich will jetzt anders
rum machen, ich will a, mach b, dass die neuen zuerst kommen oder die alten zuerst, die alten
zuerst, die neuen zuerst oder die alten zuerst, die neuen zuerst oder, die neuen zuerst, guckt
euch, das hier ist das neueste, wenn ich das jetzt schließe, und wieder oben, und jetzt
wieder oben, ok, Funst, alles gut, boah, das ist ja sowas von hässlich hier, neu zuletzt,
ja ist so, ein wenig neu zuletzt, ne, neu ist als erstes hier jetzt, also das hier ist
quasi das neueste, oder auch nicht, das zweitneueste, ne so ganz funktioniert das noch nicht oder,
ok sag, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, neu, so, man könnte tatsächlich noch nen sortbutton
einbauen, so jetzt mach ich das zu und jetzt sollte es wieder oben hingehen, ja, so und
jetzt mach ich alle zu und dann sollte trotzdem, egal in welcher reinfolge ich das anchecke,
neu wieder oben sein, ja funktioniert, der user einstellt, das ist ja schön und gut,
wenn der user das einstellen kann, ähm, ich hab aber keine Ahnung wo ich den button hin
machen würde für, müssen wir eh mal schauen, ich schreib das mal bei features hin, sort
nach, äh, erstelltatum, äh, ask und desk, so, rechts neben dem keks mit dem pfeil nach
oben oder unten, ne ich finde an die stelle passt das nicht so ganz, an den, hier machen
wir den share button, ja java script stels, unter keks tutu würd ich eine liste mit buttons
machen für verschiedene einstellungen, das ist tatsächlich ne ganz gute idee, man könnte
nämlich hier drunter, genau wisst ihr was wir machen, jetzt hab ich ne idee, hero icons,
wir machen da zwei sachen drunter, äh, book, gibts sowas, book, also wir machen einmal
ne leiste, dass man tutus quasi, dass man so verschiedene notizbücher, tutu bücher anlegen
kann, so default und eins, zwei, drei und sowas, also haben wir hier diff, so, dann sagen
wir class, text, cray 200, ne was haben wir da immer, was haben wir für nen text, cray
100, ok, cray 100, so, da machen wir jetzt noch, da machen wir jetzt noch nen border drumherum,
zwei, das sieht richtig, ih, moment, das ist falsch, den border machen wir, äh, ach ne,
class, flex, so, genau, so, ähm, hier machen wir nen border drum, da machen wir nen pinken
border drum, wie bei dem anderen, also sagen wir irgendwie, äh, ring pink 600, das ist
wenns aktiv ist, aber vielleicht nochmal mit rounded oder so, so, da kommt noch nen text
rein, haben wir hier einfach nen text, ne, p, äh, nochmal flex, null, so, äh, p, und
das ist jetzt irgendwie default oder so, so, default, so, da kanns jetzt, da kanns jetzt
verschiedene dinger anlegen, verschiedene notizbücher quasi, d.h. wir brauchen noch
nen add button, das werden wir aber heut garantiert nicht alles implementieren, äh, wobei eigentlich
kann ich das mal komplett copypasten und dann das svg rein, zwei buttons sind schon inkonsistentes
styling, warum ist doch gar nicht inkonsistent, wir haben den button, das ist unser add button
und das ist der bücher add button, so, der unten hat bg color, stimmt, vielleicht sollten
wir dann bg color dahinter machen, was brauchen wir, margin, ich kann mir das immer nicht
merken, ist margin das außen oder das innen, das ist padding, ne, margin, margin will ich
haben, ne, so, ein component svg, stimmt, eigentlich hatten wir uns heute auf die Fahne
geschrieben, wir machen noch paar components, weil wir haben mit diesem, mit dem rumgebastelt
von 130 zeilen sind wir jetzt schon mal 185 und ich blicke langsam auch nicht mehr durch,
wenn ich ehrlich bin, das wird mir schon bisschen zu sehr unübersichtlich, ja, wir machen,
wir machen components draus, das sollten wir wirklich machen, das machen wir jetzt, das
ist, da kann ich ein bisschen brain abschalten bei, ich mein hübsch, ist das jetzt denn
unbedingt, also schön ist was anderes, aber wisst ihr, wie das von der Idee halt gedacht
ist, man kann hier so verschiedene Bücher anlegen und mit dem plus button adden, sowas,
so und, aber, ne, wir müssen, wir müssen da glaube ich wirklich, Leute, wir müssen
da Hintergrundfarben machen, wir müssen da, wir müssen da wirklich Hintergrundfarben
machen, allerdings nicht pink, wir brauchen noch eine normale Buttonfarbe, irgendwie ein
helleres blau oder so, wir brauchen noch eine extra Buttonfarbe, weil aktuell haben wir
zwar ein, quasi so Action Button, aber wir brauchen ja noch so normale, normale Buttons,
die man als Buttons erkennt, gradient, ne, das sieht doof aus, ich glaube, das muss
einer, da machen wir keinen Ring da drum herum, sondern, sagen, bg, ne, das sieht, das sieht,
das sieht auch scheiße aus, ne, das sieht auch richtig, das sieht auch richtig dumm
aus, ne, das sieht auch dumm aus, ja, vielleicht, ja, das ist gar nicht so übel dafür, oder,
das passt doch eigentlich ganz gut zu pink, so, aber wir müssen auf jeden Fall noch hier,
also das da unten, das mache ich erst mal weg, das ist mir jetzt zu viel, zu viel Kram
auf einmal, also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen, ne, wir brauchen keine
Margin, wir brauchen noch ein Padding, das Ding ein bisschen größer mit, so, das sieht
doch tatsächlich sogar ganz hübsch aus, vielleicht sollten wir noch sagen, Hond Bolt, oder sowas,
ja, das sieht doch eigentlich ganz gut aus, oder, ja, manchmal sind ein paar Abstände
nicht schlecht, Pointer, Hand wollen wir haben, ne, Cursor, Cursor Hand, Hand, ne, Pointer
ist es, nicht Hand, guck mal, jetzt kriegen wir auch was, so, Pointer, ne, User Select
muss aus, Select, Select, nein, genau, jetzt kann ich ja so viel draufklicken wie ich will,
es passiert nichts, wir müssen uns eh noch ein paar, wir müssen uns eh noch ein paar
gescheite, paar gescheite Hover Styles für solche Buttons überlegen, wie wäre es denn
zum Beispiel Hover, Scale, 100, 25, oh, viel zu fett, 100, 110 oder so, ich glaube wenn
wir da noch sagen Transition, dann ist das gar nicht so kacke, oder, gibt es noch 105
vielleicht, das ist gar nicht mal so mies, guck mal, das ist gar nicht mal so mies, ja,
wir machen noch, wir machen, ne, bei dem Default machen wir noch ein, das ist Pogge, Poggie,
nicht Puppge, Poggie ist das, was machen wir, Margin, ich wäre hier noch zum richtigen
Webnative, Cloudnative, Web-Developer hier, ja, das kann man doch, das kann man doch
sich durchaus angucken jetzt, guck mal, unten drunter mit dem Pink, der Leiste, sieht das
gar nicht mal kacke aus, wieso wird die Procrast Bar komisch, an der Procrast Bar passiert
überhaupt nichts, wenn ich über den, ach so, Moment, doch, Zack, ist das ein Anzeigefehler,
ne, der Button, der Button hovert über die Procrast Bar, ich glaube da stimmt irgendwas
nicht, wir können es mal versuchen nachzustellen, indem ich, indem ich es mehr skalieren lasse,
machen wir 150, da soll es ja besonders auffällig sein, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das für
ein Bug ist, vielleicht ist es wirklich ein Render Bug oder so, oder machen wir es noch
mal größer, machen wir es mal 200, ne, gibt es nicht, was gibt es denn da noch, 200,
was ist denn das größte, 150, ach 150 ist das größte, aber wenn 150 das größte ist,
dass das nicht reicht, warte mal, man konnte doch so einen One Way machen, war das jetzt
Scale, ne, Moment, Transition minus Height, ok, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich das mache,
kann ich da jetzt eigene Werte reinschreiben, dafür bin ich zu tailwind noobish, wow, also
ich habe keine Ahnung, was das für Schmerzen hat, ehrlich gesagt, mit der Procrast Bar,
das sieht mir aus wie irgendein Anti-Alasing Fehler oder so, aber ich lasse es jetzt auf
100, 110 war das, 110, das sah noch wirklich ganz gut aus, oder 105, 105, was hatten wir
davor, ich habe es schon wieder vergessen, 105, ok, man macht immer ewig mit sowas rum,
obwohl das das Unsinnigste überhaupt ist, ist das dein eigener Server, ja, das ist irgendeine
Triple Core Hetzner Cloud Kiste, wo ihr euch übrigens noch bis zum, ach so meinst du mit
eigener Kiste, ne, das ist Hetzner Cloud, wo ihr euch übrigens noch bis zum 31.12.,
also nicht mal lange Zeit, 21 Euro Startgutschein gesichern könnt und denkt dran, dass ihr
Code Max21, also mit 4 eingebt, beim Einlösen, POG, POGG, so, was hatte ich gesagt, machen
wir als nächstes, ach wir wollten versuchen ein paar Sachen in den Komponenten auszulagern,
weil das langsam etwas, etwas Paynes Champig wird, wenn ich mir das hier so angucke, ok,
probieren wir das mal, ja, bin ich gespannt, wo macht man Komponenten überhaupt rein, in
welchen Ordner gehen Komponenten rein, unter Roots ja wahrscheinlich nicht, äh, wo gehen
dann Komponenten rein überhaupt, Moment, wir gucken uns einfach mal, wir gucken uns
einfach mal, ähm, das Testprojekt an, Q-Chat, Q-Chat App, Source, Lip, unter Lip, i, doch
Dark Steam, unter Lip, Source, Lip, Roots, ok, unter Lip, da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf
gekommen, aber ok, also Source, New Folder, Lip, so und da legen wir jetzt mal unten drunter
an todo.swelt, ok, dann probieren wir das, dann machen wir doch mal jetzt eine todo Komponente,
das heißt da drin brauchen wir auf jeden Fall, bisschen JavaScript und brauchen HTML Zeug,
wir machen jetzt einfach mal nur mal zum testen was, test, test, gucken ob das so funktioniert
mit Komponenten, wenn das ein Cloud Server ist, wieso kannst du dann über Localhost
aufrufen, achso, das hier läuft bei mir lokal, aber ihr könnt euch die Seite angucken hier
drunter, ich deploye übrigens mal, schnell mal, schnell mal deployen, bam und zack, neue
Version ist da, übrigens Firefox hat das Problem nicht, packst du das auf Shithub,
ja kann ich direkt hier danach machen, ich glaube ich bin nicht mal eingeloggt, ich bin
nicht mal eingeloggt, dann geht das von hier aus nicht, aber ihr dürft mich ruhig, wenn
ich bis zum nächsten Stream nicht gemacht habe, dürft ihr mich nerven, dürft ihr sagen
das, du darfst jetzt nicht weitermachen, ihr könnt das auch klippen, du darfst jetzt deinen
Stream nicht weitermachen und du musst, geht nach pushen, was soll das werden, das ist
ne App wo ichs Welt übe, das ist nichts was man am Ende irgendwie benutzen sollte, weil
to do Apps gibt es im Dutzend billiger von App Stores bis allen möglichen Sachen, aber
wie wir alle wissen sind to do Apps quasi die Hello Worlds der Webentwicklung, so also
machen wir mal eine to do Komponente, wie importiert man den Krämpel denn jetzt, put not find
a declaration, who cares, also import und dann to do, boah, autocomplete alter, pock,
so einfach geht das und jetzt kann ich das hier drin verwenden oder wie, to do, oh, nee,
nee, so funktioniert das schonmal nicht, das sollte eigentlich test, test, test jetzt gerendert
werden, groß, ahhh, groß schreiben, custom components schreibt man groß, die App hat
ein Bug, wenn man die Checkbox vom ersten Element anklickt, wird die vom letzten angehackt,
was, oh, nein das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht, das stimmt nicht, das sieht nur so aus, der
sortiert alle Sachen die dann sind nach unten, das sieht nur so aus wenn die Sachen überall
gleich sind, guck, aber, aber er buggt, er buggt wirklich ein bisschen rum, er buggt wirklich
ein bisschen rum, das stimmt so nicht, er stimmt, stimmt, warum denn überhaupt, warum
buggt er da so rum, jebaited, aber vielleicht können wir das lösen, wenn wir da wirklich
paar komponenten draus machen, dass man da besser durchblickt, muss noch eine animation
rein, du meinst für das, für das anhaken, der checkbox, nein wir haben ja schon unsere
progress bar, hier oben sollten wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen, noch ein bisschen mehr
abstand machen oder wenn wir gerade dabei sind, progress, hier, nee, das ist der button,
marching button, bottom to, hier, es ist nicht marching, es ist padding, oder, ich verwechsel
das immer, so, so ist ok, da ist der abstand gleich, wie wenn die to do's gespeichert in
deinem local storage im browser, aber ich werde das so machen, dass du dir das, dass
du das sharen kannst, du kannst das einfach als base 16 exportieren, jemand anderem schicken
und dann lädst du das gleiche wieder, ok, also das mit to do rendern hat aber funktioniert,
ok, wie können wir jetzt die to do's zu so einer component, component machen, also, was
haben wir letztens gelernt, ich habe mir das tutorial erst letztens durchgeklickt, wir
brauchen export, kons, nee wie ging das, export, kons, das ist das was man setzen kann außerhalb
von anderen komponenten, so, so ein to do braucht einen text, nee das stimmt so nicht,
du konntest schon mal gar nicht, ok, ich muss das tutorial gucken, ich muss das, ich weiß
immer wie das funktioniert, so, tutorial, props, export, ah, nicht konntest, let, also, so
ein to do hat einen text und so ein to do hat ein state ob dann oder nicht, so ein to
do hat created im prinzip das was ich als javascript dinger da angebe, meine idee war
folgende, also das würde ich aber so nicht machen wenn du ein backend hast, also meine
idee war folgende, das ist ja eine app die läuft rein kleinzeitig, also das passiert
alles im browser nachdem die seite ausgeliefert ist, so und man hat hier bei local storage,
ja Quatsch hier, bei local storage steht halt der krempel drinnen, das ist einfach das
jason als string von den to dos, guck text, titel, bla bla bla, so und was ich mir gedacht
habe ist folgendes, wir könnten das so machen, nachdem das ja nur lokalbadir im browser drin
ist, man könnte das ja so machen, dass man einen button macht sharen, so und dann klickt
man dann drauf und dann bekommt man einen link der ungefähr so aussieht, so und wenn
man diesen link da nimmt und jemand schickt, also in diesem link stecken dann halt base
64 all encoded, ich mein das ist bestimmt keine schöne variante aber was anderes fällt
man nicht ein ohne backend, da stecken halt all encoded base 64 der kram drinne und wenn
die seite damit aufgerufen wird, füllt sie das halt initial einmal und legt vielleicht
hier auch ein neues imported buch oder sowas an und so könnte man to dos quasi austauschen
als snapshot, sobald man wieder was editiert, editiert sich das natürlich nicht auf magische
art und weise beim anderen, so und um das ein bisschen zu verkleinern könnte man das
noch gzipen vorher, quasi zippen, base 64 verpacken, all encoden und auf gehts gib ihm,
hat man ein backend erübrigen sich alle probleme, also was braucht denn so ein to do als komponente,
ist dann created, was haben wir dann hier noch drinne, id, id, id, ok, eigentlich Leute
was sagt ihr, eigentlich müssten wir noch nen button als komponente createn oder, wieso
hast du kein backend, weil ich keins brauche, weil ich das alles lokal im browser speichere
und der sinn ist ja, dass ich swelt lerne und nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendeine asp.net
core craftql anwendung mache, backendless ist das neue serverless, genau, wo kein backend
ist, kann es backend auch keine probleme machen oder ausfallen, 100 prozent hoch verfügbarkeit
leute, uptime 100 prozent, wobei das stimmt ja nicht, ich brauche mir noch nen webserver
das ganze auszuliefern, aber das könnte man wirklich sehr, sehr ausfallsicher machen,
man könnte das beispielsweise verteilen lassen über netlify oder sonst was, oder aber man
würde das beispielsweise mit, keine ahnung, an 3 verschiedenen standorten sich server
mieten und es darüber ausliefern lassen, irgendwie sowas, das könntest du echt ziemlich ausfallsicher
machen, sind sweltkomponenten dann datenstrukturen, wie du gerade definierst oder ui-komponenten,
das sind alles ui-komponenten, es geht nur hier um frontendgeschichten, der also sinn
und zweck von so einer sweltkomponent ist, dass ich anstatt, anstatt sowas hier zu machen,
schreiben kann, so, das ist der sinnvolle so einer sweltkomponent und dann bräuchte ich
natürlich noch hier einen state, den ich übergebe, übrigens mir ist gerade was eingefallen,
es geht noch viel einfacher, wie wir das hier machen, wir übergeben einfach gar nichts,
wir übergeben einfach ein to do element von unserem, als javascript element, den rest
kann ich hier drinnen rendern, überhaupt kein ding, wie sieht es mit excel aus, oh Gott,
excel export werde ich bestimmen, leute, das ist nicht dafür gedacht, dass es wirklich
jemand verwendet, ja, also wir brauchen jetzt keine super krassen features, falls wirklich
jemand das, ich meine, leute, ich habe mir hier schon backup als file, excel, vielleicht
gibt es javascript xls exporter, gibt es bestimmt, js xls export, excellent export, bester name,
das muss ich eigentlich fast schon einbinden, excellent export, exquisite exportieren hier,
excellent export, excellent, javascript to export excel or csv, leute, es ist soweit,
wir machen einen excel export, excellent export, jetzt ist es soweit, ja, es gibt kein cross
side scripting, ich habe kein backend, wo irgendwas cross side gescriptet wird, es
gibt cross side, existiert nicht, wenn du als erstes großes projekt eine app machen
würdest, würdest du damit, achso, du willst eine app bauen, also die sache ist die, ich
habe von react nicht viel plan, aber ich habe von flutter auch nicht viel plan, ich würde
wahrscheinlich react native nehmen, weil ich noch mehr ahnung von javascript habe, als
von flutter und dart, achso, wenn du export mit base64 machst, da gibt es auch nicht
viel, was ich da cross side scripten könnte, da müsstest du irgendwas finden, da müsstest
du irgendeinen bug im browser finden, der json pass dazu veranlasst, irgendwelche dinger
auszuführen, die es nicht ausführen sollte, das halte ich für recht unwahrscheinlich,
ja, also wenn du eine sprache lernen willst, die noch mehr bereiche hat, dann muss es
ja auf jeden fall react native sein und javascript, weil flutter ist dart und dart hat keinerlei
ansatz, also absolut gar keinen einsatzzweck neben flutter, leute fällt euch neben flutter
irgendwas ein wofür man dart verwenden sollte, das war klar, das war klar, dass irgendwas
in der richtung kommt, ne also gibt nix, wir können uns marcel scorpion prostitution dart
channel angucken, ja, genau, der hat ahnung von dart, das stimmt, der ist big brain was
dart angeht, wie sag ich das logo von dart, dart lang logo, naja, dann muss ich sagen,
das beste an go ist eh das maskottchen, also go hat ein gutes maskottchen, das muss man
schonmal sagen, gibt es auch in allen möglichen abwandlungen, rust logo ist die krabbe, ne,
quatsch nicht das rust, das andere rust, ja das ist die krabbe ist das maskottchen hier,
dart hat, dart lang, das sieht aus als hat es irgendeinen twitter mitarbeiter entwickelt,
was zum, what, ich wills gar nicht genau wissen, hat c++, c++ hat kein logo, also kein maskottchen,
c++ hat dieses standard, hat c++ ein maskottchen, ein scheißhaufen, ja das würde passen, das
ist ein ziemlich gutes maskottchen für c++, gebe ich hinzu, also genau so stelle ich mir
das c++ maskottchen vor, ja, so wir machen jetzt noch leute, konzentraten, also wir wollen
ein to do component bauen, eigentlich bräuchte man aber noch eine, also zumindest bräuchte
man ja noch eine image component, aber ist egal, wir kopieren uns das mal raus, das diff,
so das hier wird jetzt unsere to do component, remove to do, oh ne, jetzt muss ich gucken
wie ich events werfen kann, wisst ihr was noch besser wäre, wir müssen keine events
werfen, wie schert man jetzt korrekterweise ins welt, nen objekt, also sagen wir hier
diese to do liste, wie schert man das übers welt korrekt über mehrere components, mit
nem store glaub ich, die problem ist ich hab im tutorial die sache mit stores übersprungen,
das wird das welt store, aha, oh import count from stores, ja das ist eingebaut, das ist
eingebaut, aber das hab ich übersprungen im tutorial, weil ich mir gedacht hab das, leute,
warum machen wir das nicht einfach, wenn ich das hier, moment, wie macht man globale variablen
in javascript, glaube, ne war, war oder, war, wie macht man globale variablen, ist das war,
das testen wir jetzt, could not find, nein, nein, nein, nein globale variablen, kein wundern
dass du das nicht finden kannst, ich glaub das ist nicht the way das zu machen ins welt,
ne, das funktioniert nicht, to do list is not defined, pass mal auf, ich hab die big
one, ja, was, ok, äh, wie share ich das denn jetzt, so, aha, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
NEIN, NEIN, NEIN, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE, NE,
use writable stores ok meine intention war schon korrekt import count from stores.js
stores.js import writable from store alles klar so store.js brauchen wir jetzt wo legt
man das an wahrscheinlich hier store.js wobei eigentlich sollte man das oben drüber egal
so store.js import writable from swell store const was wollen wir denn store ein to do
ja das ist ein java javascript objekt da muss man bestimmt sowas machen const count to dos
ok und jetzt importiert man das mit import count monkaS ich habe keine ahnung was ich
hier treibe aber einfach mal tutorial geskippt nur fai fat leute tun dies doch das ist kein
javascript objekt ihr habt recht chat das ist ein array und jetzt import count stores warum
stores wie war das mit dem import noch mal außerdem ist es nicht count das ist to dos
fail to resolve import stores.js da ist es doch nicht todes to dos
fail to was
hä wie fail to resolve wie man muss man mal lib
es heißt nicht stores es heißt ah guck mal da store.js und ich sollte es eigentlich stores
nennen ah da kommen wir das sache schon eher ah cannot set property of undefined source
count is count value subscribe hä ah wie kann ich den store einfach auslesen hat nicht
letztens einer was gesagt von einfach ein dollar davor machen das war doch beim progress
auch so progress guck mal einfach ein dollar davor machen hat er gesagt
was genau hat er jetzt für schmerzen das problem ist bestimmt dass jetzt to dos doppelt
dass es das jetzt doppelt gibt ne internal server error ich probiere was das ist bestimmt
so ich nenne es mal to dos hä was hat er denn für schmerzen jetzt read is self accepting
was wer accepte da self irgendwas hä ist es vielleicht so was ist denn der unterschied
zwischen mit klammern oder ohne klammern.slash stores.js ist doch da ok was genau hat
er denn jetzt für schmerzen 500 von ich weiß nicht mal von wo so ich breche das einfach
mal am start das nochmal neu stores does not provide an export named default ist mir noch
egal soll man das mal ausblühen wie es hier drinstehen hat mit der null was juckt es mich
ob die irgendwas mit default exportieren also das problem ist nicht der import das geht
jetzt weil ich es eben wenn ich es hier importiere ist das gleiche problem ne da ist jetzt doller
auf export named default ja wo ist denn das problem klammern ne das macht auch kein unterschied
oder ah keck wait hatte ich das net die ganze zeit so und hab es erst nachher geändert
ah ja alter java script please da soll nochmal einer durchblicken so und jetzt kann ich das
hier ausgeben doller to do's jawoll aber da ist ja nichts drin render render ich das
hier irgendwie to do ja so render ich das hier irgendwie mal testen ja ich render das
also hier oben sollte es jetzt eigentlich stehen ok stores to do's set 1234 aha es
funktioniert es funktioniert sehr schön so das heißt ich ersetze meine to do's jetzt
die ich hier habe durch import to do's moment was wollte ich überhaupt machen ich ich bin
verwirrt warum wollte ich das überhaupt noch mal machen ah ich wollte das machen dass ich
remove to do hier drinnen benutzen kann aber das ist doch bescheuert dann ist ja die dann
ist ja die komponente komplett verheiratet mit der oben drüber nee ich muss das ist
eigentlich schwachsinn was ich hier mache das ding das ding müsste ein event werfen
bitte to do on click das müsste ein on click removed event werfen einfach ok ok ok also
also wie war das jetzt export led to do den shit kann ich wieder rausschmeißen und hier
kann ich auch wieder rausschmeißen falls ich schon importiert habe nee 12 euro was to do's
ist not defined ja ich weiß ich weiß ok also jetzt wenn ich das to do hier rendern will dann
müsste ich hier ein to do ok wir wir wir kommentieren das mal aus ja so wir kommentieren
jetzt mal aus da sollte jetzt nichts passieren genau so und jetzt rendern wir das to do und
sagen ihm to do ist quasi das da was wir hier haben hey wie es einfach mal funzt guckt euch
das mal an wie es einfach funktioniert also was dann nicht funktioniert ist das mit dem
remove weil das nicht subscribed ist in irgendeiner art und weise zu dem event hier oben jetzt so
jetzt muss ich gucken wie kann ich scrollbar oft kann hier auch raus scrollbar jetzt sieht
man doch mal wie schön das ist wenn man das modular hat jetzt sind die styles auch nur da
wo man sie braucht so und jetzt ist die frage wie werfe ich events das was geklickt wurde
zum beispiel das stand auch im tutorial aber ich glaube das habe ich auch geskippt mit
der aussage wenn ich es brauche dann weiß ich wenn ich es brauche und habe es geskippt
events händel maus events ja das weiß ich wie es funktioniert auch klar ich muss gucken wie
man das aus einer komponente wirft ich muss quasi das was unter wie es mit ist muss ich
machen dispatch dispatch brauche ich components kann also dispatch events to do so they must
create an event dispatcher click say hallo tommy hallo ja ok on message man konnte das doch
also was muss ich jetzt machen ein dispatcher ok das ist aber schon ganz schön ganz schön
durch die brust ins auge wieder kann man nicht einfach sagen vorwarnen dass das ging doch
glaube ich auch unlike components events don't bubble if you want to listen event on some
deeply nested component the intermediate must forward event in this case you have to say
create to listening to message and create an end but that's a lot of code right so it
gives an idea forward all message events ane das brauche ich nicht das ist wenn ich das
weitergeben will das will ich ja nicht ich bin ja jetzt an der komponente die quasi sagt
ich wurde geklickt ok dann ich dann mache ich jetzt einfach so einen komischen event
dispatcher meinetwegen event dispatcher message wenn man nicht so ganz sicher was ich hier
mache dispatch delete oder so kein keine keine options on delete ich habe wirklich keine
ahnung was ich hier mache ich hoffe einfach dass das funktioniert ok remove wie wirft
man das event jetzt zurück alter component event ich blicke mal ich das jetzt jetzt
einfach mit und die lied so das heißt aber auch ich könnte dispatch die lied direkt
machen aus der geschichte hier oder da bräuchte ich das nicht ok es schmeißt schon mal keine
sinnvoll ist keine unsinnigen fehler das ist schon mal gut so und jetzt bekomme ich hier
einen event und die lied alter auto complete ich glaube es nicht kommen high iq software
hier und die lied auto complete und die lied so remove to do ob das jetzt klappt
wäre auch zu schön gewesen warum funktioniert das jetzt nicht wird denn das und die lied
wird wenigstens geworfen und die lied log 123 ok das und die lied wird geworfen aber
das mit dem delete funktioniert nicht remove to do ach die id brauche ich die id brauche
ich ok wir wir sparen uns das ding wieder jetzt immer noch das geht aus irgendwelchen
krüpp oh ok anscheinend braucht man das warum warum geht warum geht das nicht warum das
verstehe ich nicht warum geht das nicht und vor allem warum fällt das warum fällt das
ohne warum geht das nur mit so einem zwischen mit so einem zwischen event und nicht direkt
ok das ist doof aber ja gut kann ich mit leben sehr schön gut ja guck mal jetzt ist das ganze
weil es sofort ausgeführt wird wie weil es sofort ist doch ok wenn es sofort ausgeführt
wird oder was meinste da das verstehe jetzt nicht so aber da sieht man jetzt schon mal
den vorteil davon wenn man das modular macht wie übersichtlich das ganze sein kann guck
mal unsere unsere haupt ich meine das ist immer noch eklig aber die eigentliche seite
ist jetzt hier drauf geschrumpft probier das mal ok jetzt jetzt jetzt wird es highly
highly advanced massive iq also lambda stellt ok das muss mir jetzt einer erklären warum
geht das und das andere nicht ach so wenn ich das so schreibe dann führt er das beim
rendern direkt aus oder was ach so ok ja aber dann aber dann sag doch mal leute dann ist
das hier dann ist das hier wahrscheinlich die schönere variante oder ja wenn sogar
jemand sich neu ist im chat melde und sagt ja dann kann ich von ausgehen das ist wirklich
die schönere variante ja nice ok poc und die lied aber eigentlich theoretisch bräuchten
wir jetzt noch eine extra komponente für die ganzen eikens weil er würde das auch weg
fallen aber jetzt brauchen wir noch wir brauchen ja noch on was ist das für ein event bind
check dann ne das ist kein problem der setzt das to do direkt auf dann dann ist dann ist
kein problem jetzt ist natürlich die frage wenn ich das in der sub komponent auf dann
setze klappt dann das reactiv zeug hier oben drauf noch na gut können wir einfach ausprobieren
so nein das funktioniert dann nicht mehr guckt mal wobei hat das jemals funktioniert hat
er sich jemals habe ich noch nie ausprobiert chat wo können wir hier testen wir haben es
ja hier online wir können ich habe sogar noch eine alte version geladen an die brauche
ich nicht to do punkt keckwe punkt services ja guck mal der hat sich gemerkt was dann
ist das funktioniert jetzt nicht mehr wenn man das in der in der child komponent irgendwie
auf dann setzt warum nicht das ist ja ziemlich blöd
beincheckt das ist jetzt nicht mehr reactiv was ist das für ein müll wie soll ich das
jetzt ordentlich machen das ist jetzt nicht mehr reactiv weil ich es in der child komponent
verwende ja aber das ist doch kacke da muss ich ja aber das macht es doch dann viel komplizierter
dann ist es doch wieder besser ich lasse das alles im index drinne
ja das ist ja blöd wenn er sich das jetzt nicht mehr merkt das ist richtig bescheuert
das welt reaktiv objekte komponent parent vor was auch immer das reaktiv reaktiv statement
es war ein tristand wenn es baut schalke eben schalt bein was
das muss irgendwie schöner gehen ok vielleicht muss ich jetzt doch vielleicht muss es jetzt
doch in den store sein leute wobei ne store ist auch egal ich übergebe es hier ja als
als eins ja das ist das das ist ja müll da habe ich jetzt da habe ich jetzt wirklich
keine sinnvolle antwort drauf wenn es wenn es reaktiv die zeugte aber warum funktioniert
es denn nicht mehr ja da bin ich jetzt überfragt das ist irgendwelche
zwelt internen geschichten wir gucken uns einfach mal zwelt jetzt geht ab die haben
noch eine to do ab die haben noch eine eigene to do ab drinne da gucken wir uns jetzt einfach
mal ab ab wie die das gemacht haben wobei ne wir können es doch hier angucken noch
hier cd repos zwelt und dann haben wir doch hier cute cute chat app das ist das demo
projekt counter so wo sind denn die ganzen to do's about index to do's hier type das
ist ja ok das ist typescript stels wo rendern die das each to do ja das ist genau das was
ich auch mache witzigerweise ich habe da noch bis heute nicht reingeguckt aber gut es gibt
ja nur eine was ist das denn hier für big brain zeug transition scale local was ist
das animate flip das irgendwelche ne das ist doch auch tail ist es auch tailwind oder gachirol
ne wo kommt wo kommt denn das her das eingebaute animations kram animate vielleicht ist es
eingebaut das welt animations kram aber dann ist es garantiert keine css geschichten sondern
irgendwelche javascript sachen ja kommt man die haben auch keine to do komponenten kommt euch
das irgendwie bekannt vor das ist genau das das ist genau das was wir machen ja die haben keine
to do komponenten na super da kann ich mir jetzt auch nichts abgucken aber das ist ja hängen geblieben
warum ich weiß gar nicht nach was ich da jetzt suchen soll wenn ich ehrlich bin muss man das
irgendwie muss das irgendwie reaktiv da vorschreiben ok das ist ok ich weiß aber nicht zu swelt pop parent
reaktiv prop update from parent was spreading pops nested triggers komponent binding ok tutorial
stellts auf gehts bind value pin just as you can bend to properties of dom and you can bind to
component props ja ich will aber das umgedrehte haben weil das was ich hier übergebe ist ja
schon das to do oder muss ich dann sagen nee nee das ergibt keinen sinn feind feind
nee
ich das kommt ja aus dem parent und übergebe ich an an die an an die child component so und
wenn ich darin jetzt hier den state update dann kriegt das parent das nicht mit ausprobieren
ob es das wirklich nicht mitkriegt das bekommt das nicht mit das ist kacke ok da habe ich
jetzt keine lösung für keine sinn keine sinnige das nicht das event forward ich meine ich könnte
sicherlich den event werfen das würde das das das würde schon funktionieren ich könnte so was
sagen wie und checkt oder so und checkt so dann muss ich jetzt aber sagen und
checkt
nee das ist ja hier das ist ja to-way data binding das ist ja viel das
ist ja noch viel besser als den event zu werfen jetzt müsste ich und checkt und
und und und uncheckt händeln das ist doch richtig das doch richtig bescheuert ok und
checkt geht sowas ok probieren wir mal aus was jetzt passiert wenn ich hier noch sage
und die liet und und checkt und da muss ich jetzt brauchen jetzt extra wobei ich könnte
ich könnte direkt sagen hier du dann gleich ja nicht nicht gleich zu das ist halt kacke
sondern checkt status irgendwie nö wird das überhaupt wird das überhaupt geworfen console
log nö ach nee da musste man auch wieder was machen da muss man jetzt wieder den da machen
das funktioniert und ok und checkt gibt es als event anscheinend gar nicht ja da bin
ich jetzt wirklich überfragt wie würde man das denn jetzt machen also es gibt keine events
was gibt es denn hier für on
und change nee change und change ok und checkt was hältst du von custom mechanischen keyboards ich
habe noch nie ein custom keyboard gehabt ich habe hier ein logitech mechanisches keyboard auf der
bei ducky one skyline die kontext api jetzt wird es aber das ist relativ basic geschichte
das komme ich mir gleich an so und jetzt sollte er zumindest jawoll ok ok das funktioniert
und checkt und jetzt kann ich hier sagen und und checkt und wenn ich wo kriege ich den status
hier state da müssen wir jetzt auch sagen ob das oft oft oder on ist
ach du scheiße was denn das sehe ich da nicht einfach ob es oft oder on ist
alter javascript type checkt warum steht den event alter warum steht in diesen event properties
nicht drinnen ob es jetzt an oder aus ist ok checkbox mozilla zeigt mal her was gibt
es dafür events change ja super taget value event tagt das ist ja abartig
also also kann ich ja quasi sagen hier taget zeigt man ja wo ist es denn taget ist null wird
er immer schlimmer ja taget checkt ok also kann ich das dann hier
drinnen umbiegen taget checkt so und hier bekomme ich dann raus ob true oder false von
so log warum ist das jetzt ein custom event moment gibt es da gibt es da zwei da zwei
was zum geier alter was ist das wieder für javascript gedöns
nee nee nee nee nee nee document get element by ad damit fangen wir hier erst gar nicht
an detail ok dispatch ich muss das muss ich jetzt hier noch mal kurz in der hilfe angucken
bindings events so event detail ja klar das kann ich machen
das input Leute hört mal doch mal auf die doko fortzulesen und irgendwelche sachen raus
zu pasten nein das ist überhaupt nicht das problem das ist überhaupt gar nicht das problem
das problem ist ich habe eine child component die eigentlich genau das gemacht hat was in
der doko drin steht das problem ist jetzt dass ich den state in in der parent component brauche
um dass das dort sich dinger automatisch aktualisieren wenn ich das direkt in der parent component
drin stehen habe ist es kein problem aber wenn ich bein mache hier auf das to do in der
child component dann geht es nicht und ich habe keine ahnung wie ich den state darauf
kriege handle message machen die einfach handle message hier event details text also ich meine
ich kann also das ist das event was detail was details oder detail so und jetzt haben
wir hier wieder event custom event target null was jetzt blick ich dann mal durch ok
jetzt blicke ich wirklich nicht mehr durch und es ist auch nicht so als gäbe es da irgendwie
zwei sachen also das problem ist folgendes guck mal ich hatte hier sowas
moment ich bin zu weit
so ich hatte hier sowas bind checked to do dann so dadurch das ist ja jetzt so to
way data binding so dadurch dass ich das in der child component dass ich das angeklickt habe hat
er automatisch hier oben dieses reactive ding ausgeführt also sobald sich ein to do geändert
hat in to do's hatte dieses reactive ding ausgeführt was unter anderem halt die sachen
im local storage gespeichert hat funktioniert wunderbar jetzt wenn ich das to do beinde in der
child component ich habe das jetzt ausgelagert von index ich habe jetzt sowas hier das ist
schwachsinn ich habe jetzt sowas hier gemacht so und wenn ich jetzt hier klicke ist es nicht
mehr reactive im parent obwohl ich gesagt habe ein check so bein reactiv welt parent child ein
parent store vom child meinetwegen ich will einfach nur wissen wie es funktioniert vielleicht brauche
ich irgendwie es ist er rief wahrscheinlich hast du irgendeine ahnung das nächste was ich
gesagt habe ist man will nehmen jetzt ein event aber das ist eigentlich dann voll durch die
brust ins auge das durch irgendein event zu schleusen wenn es doch two way data binding gibt
ist
Bind, Reactive, Parent Child, Svelte, Svelte, na das Problem ist, also normalerweise, wenn
ich das hier anklicke, die Checkbox, dann setzt er das To Do auf Done.
Soweit klar? So und wenn er das To Do auf Done setzt, dann
läuft hier oben dieses Reactive Ding, weil sich To Do geändert hat und er schreibt es
in Local Storage. Das läuft nicht mehr.
Seitdem ich so eine Child Component draus gemacht hab aus meinem To Do und es da drinnen
bindet und da bin ich jetzt echt, ich mein klar, ich könnte das wie gesagt über irgendwelche
Events schleusen, aber das kann doch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache sein.
Wenn es Two Way Data Binding gibt, ich hab ne Idee, was wir nochmal probieren könnten
ist, updated der das überhaupt im Parent oder nicht?
Wir machen jetzt mal was, was man normalerweise nicht macht, aber einfach Set Intervall, dass
ich mir das ausgeben lasse, was in To Do drinnen steht, alle Sekunde, so To Do's, ok, so man
sieht die To Do's stehen auf False, so und jetzt sagen wir mal hier alles auf True und
die Dinger stehen auf True, aber das klappt nicht, ja das, da finde ich aber meinen Fall
nicht drin wieder in dem hier, das ist wenn du ein Child Property irgendwie Binden willst,
aber ich übergebe ja das To Do an das Child und ich will nicht im Parent mich an ein Child
Dings Binden, sondern ich will einfach gar nichts machen.
Ich will ihm das To Do übergeben und der Rest soll automatisch funktionieren, weil
so hat es ja auch funktioniert, wenn es im Parent drin steht, also da finde ich jetzt
nicht den Zusammenhang so richtig dazwischen.
So der aktualisiert das hier auch drin in To Do's, aber was ich nicht verstehe, guck
mal, der aktualisiert das, aber warum läuft denn jetzt das Reactive Zeugs nicht, wenn
das hier auf, ich meine es funktioniert ja offensichtlich, glaube das Bind fehlt, wo,
meinst du hier direkt Bind To Do sowas, meinst du das muss so gemacht werden, meinst du das
muss so gemacht werden, easy, ok das war glaube ich jetzt zu einfach, das war glaube ich jetzt
zu einfach, achso, ja das ist ja easy, ok das habe ich aus dem Beispiel nicht extrahieren
können, dass das so gemeint ist, ja dann ist doch, ok dann ist ja easy, ok jetzt zack,
am, Funst, genauso muss das sein, chat jetzt tut man nicht so als hätt ihr es verstanden,
die Zoomer ist wieder hier, die ganzen Zoomer, wobei ihr seid wahrscheinlich genauso Boomer
wie ich, ja das ist ja easy, ja so ist doch viel besser, ok, dann kann ich mir dieses
oncheckt und das ganze geduldens sparen, so und jetzt, nachdem wir das jetzt haben, jetzt
eigentlich wäre es doch auch noch gut, wenn wir uns irgendwie so eine Art Image-Image-Component
bauen oder, weil naja, das mit den Bildern ist auch nicht so schön, gibt es nicht schon
fertige Zwelt-Hero-Icons, welchen Windows-Manager ich benutze, achso, ne ne, das ist keine Windows-Kiste,
das ist Linux, ich hab Windows am Start und ich hab auf, ich zeig dir mal wie es ist,
ich hab auf dem zweiten Desktop, ich hab drei Desktops auf, auf dem ersten Desktop ist
mein Windows, auf dem dritten Desktop ist hier mein Cloud-Gedöns, wo wir die Sache
drauf laufen haben und auf dem mittleren Desktop ist eine Forever Workstation im Fullscreen,
die Linux laufen hat, ich weiß, das sieht schön seamless aus, ne, es ist aber ein Linux
und es ist echt angenehm zu benutzen, es ist einfacher Linux in Windows zu virtualisieren
als Windows in Linux, Acts getropped wieder hier, zeig mal hier, Svel, Svel Hero-Icons
NPM, zeig mir, gibt es da irgendwas mit gescheiten Download-Zahlen, 25 Sterne, 25 Sterne, 12 Sterne,
ok das Ding ist halbwegs aktuell, das können wir gleich nehmen, NPM, Svel Hero-Icons und
dann sagt man was, add this to your white config.js, was, i, ich muss zusätzliche
Configs machen, ne ne ne ne, ja i3 für Windows wäre richtig, Poggers, was machen die da,
Boah, nee, das ist mir zu umständlich.
Du, tu, tu, v.a. muss man da noch den komischen Dinger rumfuddeln, nee, nee.
Ich meine, es wäre schon cooler, wenn wir hier sowas hätten, wie, sagen wir mal, Icon.
Icon. Und was ist denn das jetzt überhaupt für ein Icon?
Steht das da irgendwo noch? Nee, das ist das SVG. Also, keine Ahnung,
wenn ich sowas sagen könnte, wie Icon Trash z.B., das wäre natürlich viel praktischer
als so ein Ding hier. Aber man kann ja alles haben.
Es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal deutlich, deutlich schöner anzugucken, wenn wir das
To-Do als extra Komponente haben. So, ich glaube, mehr müssen wir gar nicht
machen. Das tut es jetzt erst mal, das To-Do als extra Komponente, den Rest können wir
so lassen. Da müssen wir nichts mehr großartig auslagern,
ist eigentlich alles ganz gut passend. So, als nächstes, was ist das?
Ah, das ist der Add-Knopf. Ja, sag mal, ich glaube, es macht doch jeder
Spaß. Die ersten zwei Komponenten, die jeder sich in so einem, in jedem Projekt zusammenbaut,
ist Button und Icon, oder? Ich glaube, wie zwei Dinger wird sich jeder
als erstes Mal zusammenbauen. Moin. Duvel 420. So, was haben wir sonst noch
jetzt? Die Progress Bar könnten wir tatsächlich eine eigene, ja, die Progress Bar würde sich
tatsächlich anbieten, dass wir sowas hier machen können.
Nicht Progress und dann Value, sowas. Ja, ja, das ist gut, das machen wir jetzt.
Da können wir nämlich noch mal ein bisschen üben. Also, ich kopiere das jetzt einfach.
Gibt es sowas wie Duplicate? Copy? Oh, egal. Progress. So, Export Value. Der
ganze andere Krempel kann eigentlich weg. Brauchen wir hier nicht. So, die Progress
Bar kommt da rein. Sonst? Ich glaube, mehr brauchen wir eigentlich
gar nicht. Michael 50 Billion, das ist immer schön
zu sehen, wenn Du da bist. So, Value. Moment, was ist das? Warum ist das
ein Store? Ah, das ist ein Store wegen dem Kram hier.
Das ist sogar noch besser, wenn wir das auslagern, weil dann haben wir den Mist nicht in der
Hauptkomponente. Leute, wie macht man das eigentlich?
Export immer oben oder immer unten? Mein Imports sind oben, das verstehe ich.
Import immer unten? Gibt es da irgendwie so eine schlüssige JavaScript-Logik?
Export direkt nach Import. Leute, mein Visual Studio Code ist gecrasht.
Ich verstehe immer noch nicht, warum das hier manchmal crasht.
Hatten wir gestern auch schon. Hier sind wir.
Das ist irgendwas anderes. Ah, das ist die Beispielanwendung.
Ja, Elektron im Einsatz. Elektron live. So, Process is not defined.
Die ganzen Imports hier brauchen wir noch. So, und jetzt sagen wir nämlich anstatt Progress
hier, sagen wir einfach nur, Progress, äh, wait a minute, wo setze ich den Progress überhaupt?
Ah, Zack, jetzt, jetzt, Progress set. Ach so, das setze ich ja hier drin.
Dann muss ich das, okay. Ich meine, das kann ich auch alles in die Komponente auslagern
eigentlich. Was läuft da für Musik? Das ist irgendeine
Nintendo-Playlist. Irgendeine, so, also wir können das da wegmachen
und sagen, Progress, hat er das jetzt automatisch importiert eigentlich? Ist er so schlau?
Boah, guckt mal hier. Massive big brain. Block was left open. Ach so.
Progress is not defined. Ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Progress is not defined. So, jetzt passiert natürlich nichts.
So, dann geben wir unsere Progress rein und sagen ihm, wir wollen, wir wollen nicht wirklich
value. Wie machen wir das jetzt, wie kriegen wir
den Wert, wie kriegen wir den Wert? Ich meine, ich kann ja von hier das nicht
direkt in die Komponent schreiben. Kann ich jetzt sowas hier machen?
Let progress, das ist zwar nicht schön, aber das müsste ja erstmal funktionieren.
Nee, nee, es funktioniert nicht. Warum nicht? Weil es value heißt und nicht
progress. Value heißt das. Ohje.
Value is not a store, but it's a subscribe method. Ach so.
Okay, Moment, jetzt. Moment, ich blicke nicht mal durch.
Das jetzt, das jetzt ist wieder zu viel Svelte-Magic. Ich setze das value hier doch.
Hä? Wenn ich das rausnehme, aber da ist es nicht
mehr animiert. Jetzt ist es nicht mehr animiert.
Und jetzt? Ja, nee, das gefällt mir auch nicht so.
Nee, das ist kein, das ist kein Store. Das ist einfach ganz normale Variable, aber
das ist nicht schön gemacht. Na, der progress updaten sich.
Warte mal, wenn du sagst Stores sind überall verfügbar.
Das heißt, das ja im Endeffekt auch. Wenn ich. Hä, das wäre jetzt nee.
Aber das ist doch jetzt nicht im parent verfügbar auf einmal.
Kann ich das? Kann ich das exportieren? Echt?
Okay. Ja, aber.
Ich kann doch jetzt. Hä?
Ich kann doch jetzt nicht einfach im, im, im, das da das gleiche nochmal machen im.
Um drüber. Das habe ich doch schon mal angelegt.
Nee, das kann so doch nicht funktionieren. Ich meine, ich müsste wahrscheinlich jetzt
sowas hier machen. So, aber das ist alles, das geht, das geht
auf jeden Fall, das geht auf jeden Fall besser. Ich müsste jetzt hier sowas sagen.
Und dann müsste ich hier progress nehmen. Guck, jetzt ist es animiert, jetzt funktioniert
es. Aber das ist sehr, sehr umständlich gemacht
jetzt. Das muss ich mich auch ein bisschen mit beschäftigen, wie das funktioniert.
Import, progress, from to do so. Ach so.
Also quasi. OK, OK, das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren.
Also ich mache jetzt das hier. Value können wir uns also schenken.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
OK, also export. Nee.
Einfach hier export davor schreiben oder was? So, so und jetzt import, progress, from,
was? Dollar lip slash progress.
So was da. Ernsthaft?
Das geht jetzt? Nee, Moment. Moment, das heißt doppelt.
Ich habe jetzt progress, progress und hier. Also muss ich, was muss ich denn jetzt machen?
Sowas? Alter, davon habe ich echt keinen Plan.
JavaScript, lull. OK, das kann ich aber nicht doppelt progress
nennen, da versteht ja kein Mensch mehr was. Progress ist not a valid SSR component.
Was? Import, progress, progress. Oh Gott, ich blicke nicht mal durch was zum.
And why? Does not provide an export named progress. Muss ich da sagen, let anstatt konst jetzt?
Nee. Alter.
Das ist Monarchs, da blicke ich nicht durch das mit.
Das ist mir zu hoch. Das ist, das ist, das ist mir zu hoch.
Das ist script magic, Alter. Blicke noch irgendjemand durch.
Ich nicht. OK, das, das gibt es nicht.
Aber warum nicht? Oder vielleicht doch als Konst oder gar nicht?
Einfach so? Nee, nee, nee, so funktioniert das schon mal nicht.
Aber warum sagt er mir, dass es. Das not provide export, aber das heißt doch
genauso, dass sie bettet, dass sie bettet, darf das vielleicht ich denn es einfach pro
darf das vielleicht nicht gleich heißen. Wenn es wenn es klein und groß.
Das soll provide an export named pro. Wir kommentieren das mal aus, weil man nie
weiß, was Sache ist. Oh, oh, er erkennt auch nicht, was es ist.
Ob ich das hier mit dem export gemacht export let to do und es ist nicht so, dass man irgendwie
so machen muss. Ich habe also da hört es bei mir bei JavaScript
Sachen auf. Es ist nicht, dass man es irgendwie so machen
muss, oder? Nochmal irgendwie, nee, das ist schon, ist
schon richtig so. Das not provide an export named pro.
Vielleicht irgendwas, weil ich oben was mit module machen muss oder so.
Nee, jetzt, jetzt hört es bei mir auf JavaScript, Stells.
Du kannst nur. Ich ich will das Ergebnis exportieren.
Ich will diese, ich will das, was in dieser Variable drin ist, exportieren.
Da habe ich echt keinen Plan von. Ok, module exports, Pog.
Das ist genau das, was man sich an Weihnachten vorstellt.
Export Function, stop all. Nee, ich mache hier export, export let,
nicht export Function. Du könntest das in eine Store JS.
Ja, das habe ich ja schon gemacht, aber dann, dann ist das andere ja fast einfacher, weil
ich will, ich will ja kein extra. Guck mal, wenn ich hier eine Komponente habe,
die alles enthalten soll für diese progress bar, warum sollte ich dann in irgendeine externen
Store Datei irgendeinen Mist reinschreiben? Das module script ist das Magic, ich weiß
nicht, wovon du sprichst, keine Ahnung. Hier das da oder was?
Aber dann funktionieren die anderen Sachen doch nicht.
Ok, wo hat er jetzt noch was von progress? Hier, value, value gibt es nicht.
Und das Funktion jetzt oder wie? Ok, das soll jetzt funktionieren, also das
heißt, ich sag jetzt hier importier, pro, pro ist jetzt set, percent, ach jetzt rennt
er das gar nicht, weil ich das auskommentiert habe, ok, pro, hey, das Funktion, was hat
er hier eigentlich für Schmerzen jetzt? Export Kunst kann ich jetzt machen, weil ich
es nirgendwo anders beschreibe oder wie, Neusätze. Ach du scheiße Leute, chat, Monarch S hoch
10, wer soll denn das checken man? Boah, das sind echt wir gewesen jetzt, nein,
das ist nicht schlimmer als C++, das ist garantiert nicht schlimmer als C++, aber das ist schon
ein bisschen verwirrend jetzt im Endeffekt, weil jetzt habe ich hier oben diese reactivity
Geschichte und hier unten den progress, super. Woher weiß ich jetzt, dass ich hier oben gucken
muss, dass ich weiß, was da reinkommt. Das ist nicht so schön, ich weiß nicht, also
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so wirklich schick finde ich das jetzt nicht. Also, weiß nicht,
so wahnsinnig überzeugend tut mich das jetzt grad nicht, aber ich meine es ist schon mal
schön zu sehen, ist wieder kaputt, warum ist jetzt kaputt? Irgendwas kurz broken. Könntest
du, ja, also ich habe hier auf GitHub zwar nicht so ganz aktuell, aber halbwegs aktuell,
bisschen von meiner config oder das meiste von meiner config, die statusleiste ist drinnen,
die shellconfig ist drinnen, ich glaube die vimrc ist auch halbwegs aktuell, ja, da ist
nicht viel drinnen in der aktuell, ja genau, ich habe ja mein ganzes aufgebohrtes vimzeug
weggeschmissen, das t-max zeug ist drinnen, irgendwelche Startscripts und die configs
für i3 sind drinnen, genau, ja, ne, aber das hat mich jetzt wirklich so echt die letzten
Nerven gekostet, das finde ich auch nicht schön lesbar, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Ich fände
es viel schicker, ich meine sowas, ne das unten reinschreiben ist auch blöd, ich meine,
was ich machen könnte, ich habe eine Idee, was ich machen könnte ist auch sowas hier,
wie ging das, Dollar Percent gleich so irgendwie, ne Dollar Doppelpunkt Percent gleich so Unexpected
Token, dann ist es nicht gleich, ne Moment, zu viele Klammern, ne zu wenige Klammern,
so Percent sollte sich jetzt ja updaten, automatisch, so da könnte ich das hier nämlich wegschmeißen,
würde sagen Percent, geht jetzt hier unten rein als Let als Value, mal gucken, mal gucken
ob das Sinn ergibt, was ich hier baue, ja ja, Bind, ne, ne Value, ne das geht jetzt
hierfür wieder nicht, ne, kann ich nicht sagen Value Percent oder so, oder doch, ne, Request
in Module does not provide an Export Name Pro, weil ich, ah weil ich sie oben noch stehen
hab, ne das funktioniert dann von der Logik her nicht, Value Percent, ne ich glaube, das
funktioniert nicht so, wie ich mir das jetzt gedacht hab, ne egal, keine Ahnung, das, es
gibt ja auch kein Value hier, Bind, das erkennt er jetzt gar nicht, jetzt, jetzt, weil das
wäre natürlich schicker, das wäre natürlich die schönere Variante, wenn ich das direkt
so aktualisieren könnte, sobald sich die To Do's ändern, ich mein das ist auf jeden
Fall lesbarer, weil dann wüsste man an der Stelle hier was reinkommt und der meckert
auch nicht, wenn man was übergibt, was es gar nicht gibt, Bind Percent, ne, das gibt
es ja in der Child Component gar nicht, wüsste schon Value sein, vielleicht, ne, aber der
kann das ja auch gar nicht checken, der müsste jetzt irgendwie checken, ne das kann nicht
funktionieren, der müsste jetzt ja irgendwie checken, dass ich nen Set machen will auf
nen Store, als Bind, das checkt der doch bestimmt nicht, ne, das, das, Checkt der das hier,
dass es nen Export gibt, ne das funktioniert überhaupt nicht, das muss man dann ohne diese
Sache hier machen, Value, hier, Percent, ok jetzt vorbei Leute, jetzt blicken wir mal
ein bisschen durch, Bind, Bind, ne, ne, ok, vergiss es, vergiss es, das mach ich jetzt
nicht, das mach ich jetzt nicht mehr, reicht mir für heute, das ist echt genug, es ist
22 Uhr, genug Progress, Action, Alter, Value is not a store with a subscribe method, warum
nicht, Anzeige ist raus, morgen dann Backend Kobol, ja, genau, morgen dann Backend Kobol,
so siehts aus, ne, ok, ne, das guck ich mir einmal an, boah genug ey, aber wir haben doch
relativ viel cooles Zeug gemacht, ich kann jetzt die letzte Version nicht mehr pushen,
weil die gerade broken ist, aber ist doch, ist doch ganz nice, da lernt man was, also
ich muss sagen, ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, mal auch ein bisschen für was ernsthafteres
Feld im Frontend einzusetzen, das macht einen wirklich gut durchdachten Eindruck, die Probleme
die ich habe sind im Prinzip jetzt hauptsächlich, weil ich selbst noch nicht gecheckt habe,
wie es funktioniert, das sind halt so Sachen, die musst du dir mal angucken und dann weißt
du auch nach einer Zeit, wieso der beste Weg ist, was zu machen, welche Konsole hat
dich am meisten geprägt Super Nintendo, ganz klar, es ist immer die erste Konsole, behaupte
ich mal, also ich denke mal bei den meisten ist es die erste Konsole, so, irgendwas sollte
ich mir doch hier noch angucken, vorhin einer geschrieben, achso to do, keqw, services, warum
geht das immer noch nicht, ist das irgendwie broken oder so, to do,.keqw, so, wisst ihr
das, hä, warum lädt denn das im Chrome nicht, der Server ist ab, müsste alles funktionieren,
funktioniert doch, alles da, bestimmt Windows DNS Cache oder irgendwie sowas bescheuertes,
so, also Server löschen, zack, jetzt gehts down, weg und Load Balancer weg, weil wenn
ich das vergesse, kosts Geld und das will ich nicht, du wirst immer benachrichtigt wenn
dein Toast fertig ist, lass mich raten, du hast das mit einer Steckdose gemacht, mit
einer Steckdose wo du gucken kannst ungefähr was das verbraucht, was dran steckt und wenn
das dann halt wieder fällt für länger als 5 Sekunden, dann weißt du der Toast ist fertig,
vermute ich jetzt einfach mal, wenn nicht, würds mich interessieren wie du das gemacht
hast, aber mit der Steckdose ist das am einfachsten, zu viel gelabert heute, guck dir mal, ich
war heute, allen Ernstens, allen Ernstes, war ich jetzt 5, 6 Stunden online heute, das
ist für meine Verhältnisse enorm viel, halber Arbeitstag, ne ist für mich schon fast ganzer
Arbeitstag, tja, guck mal ob irgendjemand on ist, den ich folge, der das bräuchte gehostet
zu werden, aber sieht nicht so aus, ne, ok Leute ich geh jetzt ins Bett, wir sehen uns
morgen früh, auf Wachestream, bis denn, machts gut, see you.